acting clerk to the front please
all right this is children and family
law Committee of the House of
Representatives and we are now going to
be hearing Senate Bill 206 prohibiting
corporal punishment in child day care
agencies and the chair recognizes
Senator Carson to present her bill
good morning Mr chairman she lasted she
lasted one minute in your spot sorry
good morning Mr chairman and good
morning member honorable members of the
House children and family law committee
it's a pleasure to be here with you
today I have for your consideration
um Senate Bill 206 which seeks to expand
the definition of endangerment to
include corporal punishment as defined
by the Department of Health and Human
Services
Mr chairman as you know this bill passed
unanimously in the Senate it also passed
unanimously out of our
um our committee and really this issue
was brought to the attention of the
oversight Commission of children's
services in which I chair and I see a
few members of that commission presently
here on the on your committee as well
and we heard testimony that multiple
families who send their children to the
same daycare facility all discovered
that a daycare worker had been
submitting their children to corporal
punishment
when the families call the police and
the Department of Health and Human
Services they were told unfortunately
there was nothing that could be done
because of a loophole in current laws
and regulations so this bill does two
things Mr chairman it makes it clear it
is a crime for a daycare worker to
commit corporal punishment and it makes
clear that corporal punishment fits the
definition of abuse in our child care
regulations
the goal Mr chairman is that this
situation never happens again to another
family I cannot imagine
being a parent a mom or a dad and
dropping my child off at a daycare
center uh thinking that they're going to
be safe and they're going to be
protected and fun
and find out that for whatever reason
and quite frankly there is no reason for
a child to be
hit or have any kind of corporal
punishment in a facility that you picked
because you wanted your child to be safe
without making these changes that
daycare worker who inflicted emotional
and physical harm on some of our state's
youngest children can work at another
facility with no licensing ramifications
Mr chairman um today here there are two
parents of one of these children they're
here to testify today as well as an
attorney who can answer any legal
questions that you might have so at this
point Mr chairman I will end my
testimony and I will try to answer
questions but please be advised the
experts are behind me I think you have a
very sympathetic audience from the
conversations held before we started one
thing I want to
say is that at the end of the bill there
is a statement it's to be that necessary
force will be limited to minimal
physical contact necessary I see so many
bills come before us that are
overreactions this was done wrong so the
the counter pose is you can't do
anything and that causes other problems
so it does not totally eliminate
physical contact correct
there was concern Mr chair because
oftentimes
um you know you have to in order to
protect a child say uh that old um story
where they're reaching for a stove and
you grab the child and you pull the
child away because you don't want them
to get hurt
um that's very different than corporal
punishment and I think this legislation
really tries to make that distinction
um or you might have a child that's
running and you're afraid they're going
to fall and you grab them so you prevent
them from falling so
um again I think this legislation allows
that flexibility because I think we all
know that there is a difference between
those two types of situations where
you're trying to protect a child from
hurting themselves versus someone who
whacks a child on the top of the head or
wax them on their bottom or grabs and
twists at their arms I think two very
very different situations
any further questions for the senator
seeing none thank you so much thank you
Mr chairman and I look forward to seeing
you all again at 11.
this is my children and family law day I
know
chair recognizes Molly Morris sets
and you asked for three minutes and I'll
give you three minutes because as I say
I think you have a very sympathetic
audience here
you do
thank you chair chairman Pearson for
um allowing me to share my experience
and I got a little emotional listening
to Senator Carson so please forgive me
um and thank you Senator Carson for
bringing this important legislation
forward my name is Molly Morissette I'm
an elementary teacher in Chichester New
Hampshire and I come to you to share an
experience experience as a parent of
young children and child care in this
state
um in January of 2022 my family
experienced something I wish to prevent
from happening to any other children and
families in the state of New Hampshire
my son Walter was three at the time and
entering a multi-age child care
classroom at a local daycare facility
early on in the fall we noticed that he
started demonstrating some challenging
behaviors he was having a lot of trouble
with impulse control and listening but
most noticeably was when we would ask
him to do something as simple as put his
shoes on in the morning he'd get this
panicked look in his eyes as you walk
towards him and would run away from us
so that sent us to seek out some
occupational therapy help to see how we
could get him kind of through these
challenges
when I received a phone call about him
being grabbed aggressively by a staff
member at his child care facility it all
made sense
we were told by the administration that
an investigation through the child care
licensing unit would be conducted and
that all of our questions would be
answered in the findings report that
report led me to be standing here today
the findings stated that the staff
member had used corporal punishment
which is against child care licensing
regulations the report also said that
the staff member admitted to using
corporal punishment at least once a week
since June of 2021 without being spoken
to by her administrator about her
behavior
I was devastated to learn that this was
going on and harming not only my son but
other children in the child care
facility as well other child care
employees were also stated in the
findings report saying that they had
shared instances with the director of
witnessing this type of abuse in the
past and nothing was done about it to me
these statements should have been
incriminating I then asked what happens
next to these individuals and the short
answer I got was nothing
how could there be no recourse or
punishment for an individual who
assaulted my child an administrator who
allowed this to happen surely there has
to be something that follows an
individual in this profession and
prohibits them from working with
children again
as an educator I know the repercussions
of such behavior in a public school
setting why is it not the same for those
who work in child care after many
conversations with a child care
licensing unit the ombudsman's office
Concord PD the office of the child
advocate and attorneys I learned that
there's a gap in the law that allows for
people in child care who commit corporal
punishment against children to get off
without any long-term consequences for
their behavior
this seems to fill the common sense test
and for this reason I'm asking that
corporal punishment be illegal in child
care facilities and that those who use
corporal punishment are prohibited from
working with children ever again when
corporal punishment is used in child
care facilities it needs to be part of
mandatory mandatory reporting and
subject to criminal charges
to be honest I thought this was already
the state of the law and was in
disbelief to find out that this pattern
of behavior could continue and that a
person who preys on the vulnerable could
just go and get another job in another
child care facility thus putting more
children at risk
thank you for allowing me to share my
experience with you it is my job as a
mom to speak for my child when they
cannot and it's part of my professional
calling to be an advocate for children
thank you for your time and I'd be happy
to answer any questions you might have
any questions from Miss Morissette
representative Bickford thank you Mr
chairman thank you
what exactly was the type of corporal
punishment that you
uh in your case because you brought this
forward
so my son was playing with other
children in the non-nap room so the kids
who didn't fall asleep at nap playing in
the non-nap room with another child and
they were pretending to wash toys with a
face cloth and the child put the face
cloth down my child picked it up the
teacher then grabbed my son by the front
of the shirt dragged him across and
screamed in his face grabbed the face
cloth and said why would you ever take
that from another child I see that
you're crying but this is all your fault
and this is the one that was witnessed
but you don't know if there were others
that were not witnessed
and then my son was again crying and
that's what led to this
any other questions
thank you so much for your testimony
chair recognizes Heather menezes do I
have the accent on the right syllable
yes perfect wonderful thank you
apologize there we go did you want me to
start over could you hear me okay
my name is Heather menezes I'm an
attorney I work at Shaheen and Gordon
um
I met Molly and some other families
because they were looking for answers
um and frankly the the answer was this
is a legislative fix
um so
basically what was was happening was the
this daycare worker was engaged in
corporal punishment of very young
children ages three and four you heard
some of the conduct that wasn't involved
uh also involved was uh physical
restraint bear hugging
um yelling
um some pretty bad things at these
children uh and grabbing and pulling
forcefully
co-workers at the daycare knew this was
happening and were reporting it to the
administration at the daycare the
daycare and also child care licensing
was of the mind that this is not
reportable physical abuse I don't know
how that's possible but that is how this
is conduct now is being interpreted
um it took a co-worker
self-reporting to child care licensing
for child care licensing to get involved
um and no doubt while I don't know the
exact circumstances this was just simply
they were fed up and something needed to
happen
um what then ensued was an investigation
the perpetrator was found to have
committed corporal punishment on several
children several times a week for over a
year the person was terminated obviously
however the daycare did not have any
finding that they failed to report
because child care licensing says this
is not reportable abuse
that's the
the amendment to you know the the 170 E4
it makes it very clear this is
reportable abuse frankly everyone I've
spoken to about this is shocked this is
not the law already
um the the other piece to this too is
that poor families like the more sets
don't have to be in the dark about
what's going on
um you know they were taking their child
to occupational therapy they didn't know
what was happening because nothing was
being reported this was allowed to
Fester
um and this fixes that the the other
piece and there's another attorney who
practices criminal law um so I'll just
generally
um go over it is uh that the the person
involved was not prosecuted because
there's another loophole in the the
criminal law that permits this sort of
conduct uh and the amendment to
um
uh where is it
62761 is designed to fix that now the
the piece to that that's important too
is if the person is prosecuted then they
will end up on the central registry if
they try to go work for another daycare
um their name will come up and that it
won't happen right now this person uh
and I don't want to name names but the
person involved uh I I believe works at
another facility with vulnerable
populations and there's no way for that
employer to have known what this person
did so it's just not right
um this legislation just simply puts the
law where it should be anyway closes
these loopholes and removes a safe
harbor uh for folks committing corporal
punishment on young children and I'm
happy to answer any questions
any questions representative Grossman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
coming before us
um what is the actual definition of
corporal punishment by the department So
currently it is defined as the
intentional infliction of physical pain
by any means for the purpose of
punishment correction discipline or any
other reason and I'll add to we did
propose in the statute to just include
the definition of corporal punishment as
it is
um in the child care licensing
regulations because that'll be easier
for child care facilities to implement
it there's no new rule they have to know
or apply because they should already be
you know aware of what the definitions
and regulations are in child care
licensing roles thank you
representative long
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
your testimony uh the uh physical
physical pain does that include
humiliation
or or scaring a child
under physical pain
it does say the intentional infliction
of physical pain by any means for the
purpose of punishment
um so I'm not I'm not sure if that would
fit that definition so perhaps that
definition needs to be tweaked as well
and and uh follow up on me by the way uh
the follow-up is on um who If This Were
to pass
and there was a violation
where would that name go that would it
would it go to the daycare licensing you
know so that
a person going for another job uh would
be flacked how would somebody know
that this person has had violated
correct um yes so it the way that the
the two pieces to this amendment goes
that there is a criminal component so in
this case involving
um the morissets the person who was
um committing this the the police
couldn't prosecute because they felt
that this person had a defense so it
wasn't prosecuted so if the the second
piece the
um
under 627 6 is passed then what that
would do is the person would then go
through the criminal justice system and
if they are committed you know convicted
of having committed this act against the
child then that person ends up on the
central registry which would then come
up then if someone tries to go
um and apply for another job
correct that would show up okay great
thank you and in addition if this comes
under 170 e 12 1 then the injunctive
relief section 22 kicks in
so an individual May Institute any in
any Court of competent jurisdiction
injunction relief so it's even broader
than
oh you're with that statutory section I
don't have it in front of me but it is
referenced at the end of Roman 2 in the
bill before us and I'm I'm just pointing
out that um the teeth that are put into
uh 170 E12 carry through
would you believe I I would have to take
a look at this
data statutory language there's another
attorney
um I have it right here and anyway thank
you okay
anyone else with a question
thank you so much then thank you for
your testimony thank you
chair recognizes Cassandra Sanchez of
the office of the office of child
advocate
good morning Mr chairman and the Steve
members of the children family law
committee for the record Cassandra
Sanchez child advocate for the State of
New Hampshire
I'm here today to testify and support
of Senate Bill 206. my office is in
support as you heard prior in some of
the testimony that some of these
families have come to my office's
attention they have come to us seeking
assistance on these issues my office has
looked into the laws that exist
currently and we found a major Gap in
the system and we are speaking about
some of our most vulnerable children in
the state who don't have the ability to
come home and report to their parents
what is going on in these Child Care
Centers it's extremely worrying to
myself and to my office we did
immediately engage with the oversight
Commission on children's services to
ensure that they were aware of this Gap
in the system and as you see Senator
Carson brought this bill forward today
so I am in support I I'm very worried
about
what currently is happening in child
care facilities you heard from one
family my office has heard from more
than one it's not this is not this one
family's anomaly this is happening more
than we would expect and would hope in
our state and as they had mentioned in
in some of the cases that we have looked
into some of these providers have then
left the facility which they were
working for some have been fired by
higher ups in in the the child care
agency but then have transitioned to
another facility so the families are
able to track that confirm that and when
we look into it we have confirmed that
as well so they continue to work in this
realm although they're not working with
the same specific children so that just
stretches the reach of their harm for
children it's not just the you know
handful of children they first had
access to they're now broadening their
reach across the state
this is very problematic too to my
office and so and unfortunately in these
cases just given the way the law
currently exists there was minimal
support we were able to provide to these
families we were able to educate them on
the law that currently exists we were
able to send them to child care
licensing and the reports back that my
office would receive is that child care
licensing could not move forward with
much more than looking into the
allegations and Reporting back to the
heads of the Child Care Agency for what
they would have found it did not move
forward with the legal process it did
not move forward with a dcyf
investigations currently special
investigations for dcyf specifically has
the investigation authority over
residential facilities not education
facilities and not child care facilities
um so as I had mentioned I am here in
support I I think it's critical that we
take the stand and and fill this Gap in
our law to protect the youngest children
in our state
um and to ensure that these providers
then cannot move to another facility and
continue to abuse children I do want to
address the question by representative
long and taking a look at the emotional
and psychological abuse and in my
understanding of corporal punishment
that does not fall into
corporal punishment so that is an area
in which I just feel we still have a gap
and may may be worthwhile taking a look
at this bill if there's a way to
incorporate that piece because as we
understand the psychological impact can
have lasting effects on a child's mental
health and well-being
and thank you I'm open to any questions
any questions
representative D Simone
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
isn't it true that uh in a child care
setting it is the responsibility of the
adult
to create a calm
controlled atmosphere yes it is follow
up thank you
if an adult gets to a point where they
are striking out verbally or physically
isn't that a person who is out of
control
yes
thank you very much thank you
representative panic
thank you thank you chairman and thank
you for asking uh taking my question
um
what is the average amount of complaints
per year that you know of
on the average for the specific issue
yes I only track the amount of
complaints that come into my office for
different issues I don't track what
child care licensing gets so this would
be the families that just find my office
over the past year we had five
complaints for this issue out of 319.
thank you
representative McMahon
chairman
relative to the bill that's in front of
us right now
and your commentary which is appreciated
which takes place after the fact versus
before the fact and that is what's to be
promulgated into law
right now it's referring uh in the bill
and you've read the full Bill yes I have
the bill before me on the line 17 where
it says a physical Force by persons with
my words quotes special responsibilities
unquote
what does that mean
my understanding and my belief is that
the special responsibilities is that
they are tasked with the care of very
young young and vulnerable children
follow up
uh
look I have a second question but uh so
it's not dealing with those with special
needs
no and not be specific to just children
with special needs it would include all
children that would attend Child Care
settings okay now next question then for
you is and within the bill itself
where it says the the
um the extent that such contact does not
violate child care licensing rules that
are already in and not going to have
that in front of me here for those
searching for it on the 541 and 170. is
the uh
the definition of corporal punishment
being what it is right now
do we need and that's for the safety of
parents making the right decision of
where they send their children but also
those providing the services
should there not be within the law a
specific
description of what is allowed or not
allowed in terms of
physical contact when it when it's
stating
in here it's for these so-called safety
of the individual I would not recommend
special language specific to what
contact can and cannot be allowed I do
believe adding the definition of
corporal punishment would cover that
concern okay then final follow-up is
last year on Hospital 427 we had our
various student research resource
provide for us
where that passed a uh it was a
definition of what that is and is that
definition not applicable or or by
applicable is it appropriate now or does
that need to be further enhanced with
further specific language
I believe that that covers the aspect of
corporal punishment in in regards to the
physical aspect the physical touch but I
believe the Missing Link at this point
would be including that psychological
and emotional impact to the child that
is what the definition would be missing
thank you madam Snapchat thank you
any further questions representative
long thank you Mr chairman so I'm
looking at 161 14 2C
and it says corporal punishment means
any punishment in which physical force
is issued and intended to cause some
degree of pain or discomfort
so would discomfort be fear humiliation
I don't believe so no all right so a
discomfort is
yes okay thank you
representative DeSimone thank you Mr
chairman and thank you again for taking
another question from me um do you feel
that this particular Bill uh which
hopefully will become law uh would be
better if we included emotional and
psychological pain
I believe it would be stronger to
support the children because when we're
speaking about as we heard the mother
speak prior which is talking about the
yelling and the screaming at the
children that has as great of an impact
as physical harm to a child especially
when it's a caregiver who so this this
person is acting in the caregiver role
as as a parent would in the parents
absence absence during the day and
parents have a bonded relationship with
their child they have that healthy
attachment and so if there is yelling in
a household There's an opportunity for
repair as a parent comes back around
hugs their child laughs with them later
in the day and it has less of an
emotional impact
we're talking about a caregiver in the
setting who is acting in this way and if
they do not take the steps necessary for
the repair the damage of that emotional
trauma is as as damaging as physical
abuse
thank you so
oh so it's true that sticks and stones
can break your bones but words can break
your heart
that is true thank you let me ask a
question in order for us to work on this
bill
to add emotional distress to the child
I can see this probably have to be
retained and worked on and not come back
next year
um that's just my guess
if we were to amend this then it would
have to go back to the Senate I have to
bounce around I'm seeing in line nine of
the bill endangerment shall also include
corporal punishment as defined by the
department in your professional opinion
do you think the department could
stretch that definition
while we then work on a new build for
next year that further qualifies it
would guarantee then my opinion this
Bill gets signed into law soon whereas
are working on this and then bouncing it
back and forth May delay it would that
be something you think the department
might be able to do
I I believe I I don't know for I can't
speak for sure if they would be willing
to do it but I do believe they
um could have an easier time to stretch
that
um than working on this I will say that
if that one aspect could keep this bill
from passing this session then that is
something that I could take a step back
on and it's about the ensuring the
protections of the children now so if
that had to be added on later if it has
to be looking at it from the Department
scope I would be comfortable with that
as long as a bill can move forward to
protect children right now
and I would suggest to those who are
listening a should that be the course we
go start working on that bill for next
year yes thank you any other questions
of The Advocates
seeing none thank you so much thank you
and now I'm gonna I'm gonna take a stab
at this
the chair recognizes Anthony scalabrini
yes
oh
my name is Anthony scalabrini I'm a
lawyer in Nashua I've been practicing
for almost 20 years I do mostly criminal
work when Molly called my office and
asked me you know what's going on it
sent me on a research frenzy and only
then did I figure out that there was a
gap in the criminal code specifically
RSA 6276 paragraph two subparagraph B
this is the this is the uh part of the
criminal code that talks about the
defense for people with special
responsibilities to answer a previous
question special special
responsibilities is generally defined as
people that have some sort of
supervisory role over people that are in
need of help or children so it could be
uh you know somebody that works at a
daycare like here it could be a teacher
it could be somebody that works at a
group home those are the kinds of people
the statute and visions and it's really
important to note and this was brought
up by uh somebody about the definition
of corporal punishment the definition of
corporal punishment that this bill seeks
to incorporate is the one that's found
in the child care licensing regulations
which is
4002.01 in sub uh paragraph zero or
paragraph o letter O and that one talks
about infliction of pain the question
about whether emotional harm would comp
come into that definition it seems
pretty clear looking at how the criminal
code and how the civil code have defined
infliction of pain physical pain that it
wouldn't and if you look at something
like the case law surrounding
intentional or negligent infliction of
emotional distress the court and the
common law make a pretty good bright
line distinction between physical pain
and emotional pain and so that that's
something that this this bill if it was
made into law could look at in terms of
defining the scope of what counts as
corporal punishment the one thing that I
I want to bring to the committee's
attention is this that often times there
is a perfect solution but that solution
is
in the offing it'd be better to put in
the solution that's before the committee
today to Institute some sort of
protection and then come back later and
fix it or add to it and it's especially
important here because emotional abuse
as you can see in the case law around
infl uh infliction of emotional distress
is very difficult to define the common
law around an infliction of distress
type torts has been modified and changed
and expanded pretty regularly over the
past Century and in fact New Hampshire
relatively recently compared to other
states changed the sort of blast zone or
radius of harm for somebody and an
infliction of emotional damage case so
that case law is not something that
could be incorporated into a statute
with an easy fix whereas referencing a
pre-existing definition is really easy
and in the Senate somebody brought up
the point about does this change with
the child care providers have to do
because it's already part of the
regulation they're abiding by it doesn't
change anything they have to do it makes
clear that corporal punishment is a
crime again going back to the defense
with people with special
responsibilities there was a question
about injunctive relief on RSA 170 E46 I
do believe that this is the exact kind
of thing that could be used to get into
court in an emergency basis to stop some
kind of harm the the last another
question that was asked was where would
they be listed so specifically the if
you're convicted of a crime you're
entered into the ncic database and this
would be something that anybody who does
a general background check could find if
you go to the Department of Safety today
and you pay 25 you can get your record
you most people have to sign something
allowing them to get your record when
you apply for a job so they can do a
background check it would be very easy
it's done every day it's not complicated
um
in terms of a specific list somebody
brought up a specific list I I tend to
agree with the office of the child
advocate that making a specific list
would give us places where we introduced
new gaps or new loopholes so instead of
doing that leave it as a broad
definition one that's already in the
regulatory code one that's already been
tested and worked on by people in the
field by people that do this kind of
work and understand what it is to
inflict uh emotion physical pain on
somebody as opposed to emotional pain so
as it is right now I think that that a
list would only introduce the
possibility for more problems I'm
strongly in support of this bill hearing
Molly talk every time makes me really
proud that we live in a country where
people like Molly can come forward and
make an impact and change the law and I
strongly urge you to support this bill
and pass it counselor would you take
questions yes sir under 627 6 the 627 is
of course the chapter on justification
there is nothing in that chapter that
specifically says what we mean by
special responsibilities is however the
chapter starts by saying a parent
guardian or other person responsible for
the general care and Welfare of a minor
dot dot dot to me that is a definition
would you agree yes in fact that's how
the the rules of the Cannons of
construction work in interpreting
legislative uh and statutory edicts and
no despite a grand swell I am not going
to law school thank you any other
questions
thank you so much for your testimony
thank you
now
um I
next one all right just a word to the
committee
um
do you think this is ready to vote on
yeah all right then in that case the
chair moves a house bill
uh Senate bill
206 prohibiting corporal punishment and
day child day care centers moved by the
chair uh OTP do I have a second
everyone I recognize our one minute
clerk representative Greg thank you you
almost almost did it and uh any friend
any further discussion on this
representative Raymond uh thank you Mr
chairman very briefly I just want to
extend my appreciation and thanks to
um the group that brought this forward
this is really important and I think
affects every family in New Hampshire
most of us use Child Care at some point
and the idea of
um my kids when they were small
experiencing that I just I had such a
visceral horrified reaction
um to the testimony today so thank you
so much for bringing this to our
attention so we can fix it okay yeah
anyone else
representative Perez
yeah I would like to say thank you for
bringing this Senate bill for someone
who have a grandson he's 10 months old I
can't even imagine something happened to
my grandson right now so thank you for
bringing this forward and I'm happy to
support this bill
the motion before us is Senate Bill 206
the motion is ought to pass moved by The
Chair seconded by representative Greg
when the clerk is ready please call the
roll
chairman Pearson yes
representative long yes
representative DeSimone
yes representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon
representative ball
representative Panic yes representative
Seidel yes representative Grossman yes
I see representative Levesque is not
here
representative Petrino votes yes
representative Perez yes
representative Greg yes
representative Moulton is not here
representative Raymond yes 14-0 with two
absence
and the objections to consent
seeing none we go on to the consent
calendar
this ends the
executive session on Senate Bill
206. we've got about three minutes for
Senate Bill 179 we can always be late
but apparently we can never be early so
there we are
anybody has pink cards meaning you want
to testify on 179 write them out bring
them up bring them to representative
Bickford and they will come up
179 seclusion
do we have a card from Nami
it's
like
thank you
well I'm gonna end
up thanks
I'll take that
right out the blurbed right off the
block so I won't forget thank you
you
and I got about a minute what is this
committee it's
oh thank you wow
is this uh valued at under 25 dollars
okay good I'll take it thank you
no no that's all right she has a yeah
thank you
okay all she has to do is give me a card
I don't I don't
but I'm about to
okay oh we gotta packet good oh wow
thank you
three different items
foreign
good
one one for one packet per person yes
I'm opening the hearing on Senate Bill
179 relative to eliminating the use of
seclusion as a form of punishment or
discipline on children in schools and
treatment facilities the chair
recognizes an alumna of this committee
Senator all Schiller who's the Prime
sponsor
thank you chairman Pearson and honorable
committee members it's nice to be back
in this room
for the record my name is Deborah
alchillar and I represent Senate
District 24 which includes the towns of
Exeter Greenland Hampton Hampton Falls
Northampton rye and stratum and I'm here
to introduce Senate Bill 267 I'm sorry
um I have a lot to introduce relative to
eliminating the use of seclusion as a
form of punishment or discipline on
children in schools and treatment
facilities
as amended this bill clarifies the
legislative intent of eliminating
seclusion the involuntary solitary
confinement of a child without any
ambiguity
to be strictly prohibited I draw your
attention to section one where the
clarifying language is
seclusion shall never be used explicitly
or implicitly as punishment or
discipline for the behavior of a child
solitary confinement can cause extreme
psychological physical and developmental
harm for children who are still
developing and more vulnerable to
irreparable harm the risks are magnified
particularly for kids with disabilities
or histories of trauma and abuse the
oversight Commission on children's
services has heard reports from the
office of the child advocate that
facilities with State contracts are
using the ambiguity of current statute
to skirt the intent and are using what
is called in one facility a quiet room
as a form of discipline and Punishment
the use of isolation as a disciplinary
measure risks damaging children's mental
health and can have the opposite of
intended infect by making behavioral
problems worse
preventative and positive behavioral
strategies that acknowledge the
struggles and triggers for children who
are already challenged is a more
effective and dare I say humane way of
offering interventions
New Hampshire has made a commitment to
the multi-tiered system of support and
this committee has probably heard mtss
many times over as our framework for
enhancing the implementation of
evidenced-based practices to achieve
important outcomes for every student the
mtss framework Builds on a public health
approach that focuses on organizing the
efforts of adults within systems to be
more effective
enhanced screening of children to set in
motion behavioral modification plans
build resilience and strategize with
that child what would be an effective
way to reach them when they are in an
escalated state is best practices in
establishing behavior management plans
additionally reporting forms for
incidents in facilities working with
children is quite frankly all over the
place there is no uniformity of language
or reporting resulting in chaos of
interpretations and I draw your
attention to the packet that you've
received
in order to establish a rubric for
uniform best practices Statewide
this Senate bill as amended will engage
the Department of Education the
Department of Health and Human Human
Services
in the office of the child advocate in
developing a Statewide incident
reporting form to better assess Trends
and data in child protection
provided for the committee again as I
referenced is a packet of various
incident report forms currently used by
agencies all across the state while the
department of children youth and
families has provided an incident report
checklist the uniformity in reporting
ends right there
in the packet provided for you there's a
page from Spalding Academy
which I believe is the fourth page in
and the family services reporting form
towards the bottom of the page there are
options
for the staff
to check off and you check off the use
of techniques that were used
in managing a child
one is called the one arm wrap
there's also the Sunday stroll
the one person vertical immobilization
and the double Sunday stroll
these would sound more familiar in a WWE
ring those terms are not used on any
other reporting forms the second page
has spots for a reporting having
directed a student to a quiet area or
the use of seclusion in response to high
level Behavior clearly there is a need
for some uniform language across all of
our facilities with State contracts and
clarification in this proposal of the
words shall never
from may not be in rsa126u5
I asked the committee to affirm the
Senate position and recommend Senate
Bill 179 as amended ought to pass thank
you very much Mr chairman will you take
questions and your former committee I
would be delighted representative
Petrino
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Senator I just want to thank you for
bringing this bill forward when I was a
nursery school child I was frequently
secluded in the classroom closet for
apparently not participating accordingly
but really what I struggled with was
learning disabilities which people did
not know at the time so this one speaks
to me on a very personal level and it
did impact me adversely throughout my
Elementary School experience so I just
wanted to thank you so much for bringing
this forward thank you I'm very sorry
that happened to you
representative Perez
um similar to a several percent of
Petrino this is bringing uh
really ugly memories being punished and
being hit with a ruler
um and uh yeah I I don't want to see any
child being hit by with a ruler or um a
sewing machine Bell because that's not
how kids should be punished especially
in that environment
thank you for bringing this up thank you
very much
representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman and thank you senator for
bringing this to us
um my question is regarding
um the use of some of the calm down
spaces that we see in elementary schools
and occasionally in a residential
facility I know in Nashua for example
one of our elementary schools has a room
um it's a it's a sensory room and they
have different stations that a student
may progress through on an individual
basis uh with you know there's like
stress balls and there's some other
stuff do you see this legislation as
interfering with that kind of
therapeutic space or simply being aimed
at the you know the empty padded rooms
that we see sometimes as well
thank you very much and thank you very
much for offering an opportunity for
this clarification
um so what you are seeing in that Nashua
School when a child has to is removed
from a classroom for
um as you said maybe a calm down space
bringing them into a sensory room where
there is supervision from
um from an adult from a teacher from a
trusted trusted adult is all part of
what we have already made a commitment
to as best practice in New Hampshire of
mtss that's identifying prior to there
being a meltdown if you will who that
child responds best to in the crisis and
what are the ways that that child is
most supported in the calming down so we
can get back to regular school and
learning quicker
so this does not apply in the way that
we teach in our elementary middle and
high schools right now because we have
established those systems of support
they are not being used as a form of
discipline or punishment they're
actually being used as a way of building
resilience and keeping that child and
the other children safe
what this bill addresses is that also in
your hometown we do have a state agency
we have a contract with an agency that
actually uses a solitary room there are
no sensory
there are no sensory guides there is no
one sitting with that child there is
that child is alone in a room
four hours and we have reports at the
commission for their children the
oversight of Children's Services of days
and that child being children having
been paraded out of those spaces to eat
in solitary alone in a cafeteria and
then per and then walked back into that
space as a form of coercive control for
the other students that if you don't
want this to happen to you
then you will get in line now none of
that addresses any kind of trauma it
brings on more none of that addresses
any kind of Behavioral issues that that
child may be having related to their
trauma it makes more so children who are
in facilities with State contracts
are already traumatized they're not home
they're not with family they couldn't be
there and we need to address those
issues so taking a child out of their
environment for the health and safety of
that child and the other children is a
very different
method of building resilience and
supporting that child then putting them
into solitary confinement
thank you for the question thank you
that's a representative ball
Harrison and thank you for being here
um I'm just curious how does this impact
um in school suspensions where the
children are sometimes or at least when
I taught years ago
um the children were often kept away
from their other peers not necessarily
in a separate room but maybe part of an
office but they were not allowed to
interact with their peers so how does
this impact that in-house
so um
those children who are in a school that
the school may be using that that type
of
discipline and behavior control are not
leaving the children in a locked room or
um
keeping them confined
for hours and hours and hours upon time
it's not solitary confinement
any other questions representative
Grossman
thank you Mr chairman and welcome back
Senator thank you for being here and
bringing this forward
can you explain for us what
um there are some suggestions in this
bill as to how seclusion should be
handled on the last on page two
there are some suggestions of a
co-regulator a through d
can you just describe what is being
suggested for school districts to do
instead because they are required you
are asking for
adult staff member a trusted adult just
so the committee can understand what is
being expected if seclusion thank you
thank you representative Grossman I
appreciate you offering me the
opportunity to
point out that on page two Section 3
the a through D actually describes what
we are using in New Hampshire right now
which is mtss a multi-tiered system of
support which is to identify prior to an
incident a plan so as as highlighted
develop a plan to help the child manage
their state of Regulation and then
return to a less restrictive setting so
a child that does leave the classroom to
go to a sensory room
we're not putting them we're not just
putting them in a sensory room and you
know hoping they might
stop spinning we have a plan in place
for
um because we have we observed this
behavior before perhaps and and we have
a multi-tiered system support so we know
how that child best responds when they
are in a heightened state so that may be
bringing in you know if they have a very
good relationship with the nurse and
we're having a crisis in this moment
then that teacher would call for the
nurse to come in and have a conversation
with that child and understand that
these type of incidents in school
settings
are quick they don't last the entire
school day so we have mtss being
implemented in school settings what we
don't have is the same type of system
instituted in places where children live
and are being cared for under State
contracts so
um
that is so mtss is what's outlined in
that space right there and I just wanted
to also address
um
I missed a spot with representative
Ball's question and I would just like to
point out
um
that in section three on the first page
seclusion shall not be used in a manner
that unnecessarily subjects the child to
the risk of ridicule humiliation or
emotional or physical harm so an
after-school detention in the study hall
would be very different than putting all
of the students who had a detention that
afternoon in the front hall to be
observed by their peers as their peers
leave for the day so that would be in it
that would be an intentional humiliation
versus a consequence of behaviors where
you're going to need to stay after
school and do your homework in a
supervised setting
so very very different
follow up
thank you for that clarification thank
you I know that when I taught they were
very much against the intentions but we
used a system called lost time so that
gave the child time to stay after it
without it being a bad thing we actually
told the parents this is a good thing
because the child can now do their work
and make sure that they stay up and
don't fall into a pattern of now they're
frustrated so thank you for clarifying
yeah thank you
representative Nelson thank you Mr
chairman and it's nice to see you again
Senator hello hi uh I just had one quick
question on page two under Roman numeral
three on lines three and four
um the co-regulator shall check the
child at regular intervals not to exceed
30 minutes between any one interval
um how is that a 30-minute period of
time
um determined that was done in
collaboration with the office of the
child advocate and with other Advocates
who use mtss
yeah thank you and they're um I think
there may be yes she's here so I I
encourage you to ask that again
thank you senator
chair recognizes from new Futures Emma
savini who has handouts for all of us
and I would ask that each person who
signed a pink card uh
observed what they wrote on the pink
card meaning you need two to three
minutes because we're up against
other bills coming before us so
hello good morning thank you for having
me
um I believe my handouts already made it
around
um my name is Emma savini I am the
children's Behavioral Health policy
coordinator at new Futures new Futures
is a nonpartisan non-profit organization
that Advocates educates and collaborates
for the health and well-being of all
Granite Staters new Futures is here in
support of Senate bills 179 because
seclusion is an inappropriate
traumatizing and Dangerous Method for
discipline and should be never should
never be used as punishment for children
as you heard from the bill sponsor
seclusion can create
psychological and physical harm and in
some cases even result in death through
children being placed in seclusion and
then escalating to forms of restraint
which can result in death
New Hampshire has already recognized the
importance of banning this practice by
passing this law way back in the day and
now is just kind of tidying up the
language as you've heard it's just
closing that Gap by changing the May to
a shall never
um and instead what this bill does is
encourage therapeutic practices to be
utilized instead so as you discussed the
co-regulator method is a great way to
help children have positive behavior
interventions and those have actually
been shown to have a better impact on
behavior and a more lasting positive
environment for children
um I just would also like to highlight
for you that seclusion is
disproportionately used on children with
learning and behavioral disabilities and
with Children of color you'll see some
statistics in my written testimony but I
think that this uh change in statute
would be an excellent way for New
Hampshire to come forward and be a
leader for our country and eliminating
seclusion and taking a step towards
um being a more welcoming and Equitable
environment for all Granite State
children
I'm happy to take any questions and I
urge you to pass this bill
representative McMahon
hello Mr vigney thank you for being here
and in the interest of the lawsuit to
come I want to ask uh your clarification
or your guidance on this in the bill uh
line four
and then line five where it says that
you just indicated uh seclusion shall
never be used then in the next line it
says it may only be used so we have an
inherent contradiction in the narrative
my question to you is should that second
line be miss a none miss you eliminated
or Rewritten
um so I will give my opinion but I think
that question is better answered by some
of the folks who have done the actual
work uh writing this bill
um I think that that carve out is
specifically for those instances in
which
um you know seclusion can be used in a
safe and effective way uh like the
detention we talked about or the
in-school suspension where it's not a
traumatic event for the child and there
are other adults in the room to who can
help co-regulate in those those types of
specific situations so there is a carve
out as you'll see in that second line
where it says it may only be used
um
so but again I encourage you to ask that
question to those who may be better
suited to answer
I just wouldn't follow up then follow up
again
dealing in word meaning which
always sets the standard for what
happens next is that uh
the word never should that be would you
suggest uh that that be removed and say
shall not be used versus shall never be
used
um
again I'll defer I I would encourage you
to ask that question to
um some other folks who may be better
suited uh the child advocate or
um the attorneys in the disability
rights Center who may be able to better
answer that all right thank you ma'am
representative ball
thank you chairman Pearson
um with regard to that I'm just
wondering I know I will ask the next
person as well but maybe you can answer
this is the prob is the challenge here
using the word discipline
because as a behaviorist a discipline
gives to the child where punishment
takes away so typically we want to
discipline children not through Corporal
punishmentary but by giving them more
time giving them more space giving them
more supports that's what technically
discipline is supposed to do and so I'm
just wondering if it should just be will
she be never used as punishment
because keeping a child in a
a sensory room that's really a
discipline because we are actually
giving them the space they need to learn
the self-regulation skills so there's in
the in that sense there's a big
difference between the two words and
maybe that's where there might need to
be a clarification is that possible
um I completely understand where you're
coming from and thank you for the
question I um
I had not given that specific word that
uh meaning
um so I don't have a fully fleshed out
opinion on it and I'd have to do more
research before I could give you an
answer
um but I can absolutely look into that
for you okay thank you very much
thank you
Karen Rosenberg
good morning everyone I'm Karen
Rosenberg I'm the policy director at the
disability rights Center like I'm not
very loud right now
um I'm here to testify in support of SB
179 on behalf of the disability rights
Center also some other organizations who
couldn't be here New Hampshire legal
assistance and Waypoint who I think is
here but I'll my testimony will be for
them as well
um I think maybe what I was hoping to do
is give sort of puts put a picture on
some of the kinds of
um incidents and things that we're
talking about that we see as loopholes
to our current law which limits the use
of seclusion but I also want to address
representative McMahon's questions about
the language in the bill so
um
if that if that would be helpful and
please interrupt me with questions that
you might have so
I don't see the language as inconsistent
it actually mirrors current law as it is
now but strengthens our current law so
um So currently
as you can see when you look at the bill
um it we say seclusion may not be used
as a form of punishment or discipline
and then it goes on to explain when
seclusion may be used the reason for
this change is to make it to really
tighten it up and strengthen it so that
it mirrors the same prohibition that we
have the language we use in our
prohibition against the use of physical
restraint so if you look
further deeper into the statute I think
it's at u5 but let me just
get there
um no sorry yes
um
so our restraint law has language that
is similar in that it says it restraints
shall only be used in a score facility
to ensure the immediate physical safety
so it explains when restraint may be
used further along in the statute
however it does explain that
um restraint shall not be shall never be
used explicitly or implicitly as
punishment and why am I not finding that
because probably it is happening earlier
hold on
I'm sorry
thank you
um here we
page one section one okay
um
you know I do that I look at this all
the time
um basically it makes it very clear in
our law that restraint shall never be
used explicitly or implicitly as
punishment or discipline for the
behavior of a child and I oh it's and
I'm not finding it someone help me
section four
I'm sorry I'm looking at the statute I
know it is in here oh here it is um
you've yeah sorry about that
um it's no it's you've it is u5
um and and and essentially it's not
contradictory because we know it's it
shouldn't be used for this purpose
here's when it should when it may be
used does that make sense
no I'm so sorry
um because I like I said I didn't know
that I was going to be exactly
addressing this
ah
here it is I'm sorry it is it's in u5 so
our current law RSA 126 u5 Roman 2 says
and I read just exactly restraints shall
never be used explicitly or implicitly
as punishment for the behavior of a
child so the goal here and I apologize
for taking so long to get you all there
is to make sure that when we're talking
about seclusion and we are that the
prohibition against the use of seclusion
for punishment or discipline mirrors the
probe the language and the prohibition
for restraint the sentiment is the same
that we shouldn't be using these kinds
of restrictive Behavior techniques that
are really traumatizing on children for
discipline that's not what discipline is
discipline doesn't traumatize or
re-traumatize children what discipline
does is it tries to address behavior in
a way that will and enable the child to
understand that this Behavior not is not
just unexpected but behavior that they
should not be engaging in it may violate
a code of conduct for example it may be
putting other people at danger but it's
behavior that they need to learn how to
address and we address in different ways
in our schools and in our treatment
facilities so but one thing that is
Crystal Clear is that we address this as
a learning opportunity we want we use
seclusion and restraint only when
necessary to protect other people from
physical harm that's why it's prohibited
we you know there are times when we
can't protect some another person or the
child without using this really you know
last minute emergency response but it
should not be used in response to
something like child is refusing to
clean up after themselves swearing at
someone littering
you know refusing the first directive to
come inside from the playground
that's where we discipline we don't
seclude for that so
is that clear as mud now or clear I hope
thank you and just so you have an idea
of the kinds of things we see in our
office so we as the protection and
advocacy Agency for people with
disabilities we have special authority
to go into facilities to monitor for
people's safety interview folks who are
in those programs and this includes
children's facilities and so what we've
seen over the years is the that even
though the numbers of recorded reported
seclusions have really declined
radically particularly in facilities
that serve our children we're we're
hearing about ways that
um schools and facilities are kind of
like navigating around our law so for
example current law says it's not
seclusion if you drag a child into a
room shut the door tell them they cannot
leave or they know that if they leave
they'll be restrained as long as that
door is unlocked
right so children no they've learned
don't open that door because either
they've seen another kid get restrained
after trying to open the door or they
know they'll lose privileges or they've
been basically you know like terrorized
to stay in the room
the experience for the child is exactly
the same but our law currently says well
if that door is unlocked that's not
seclusion then it's not reportable it
can be used for any kind of behavior
you're subjecting the kiddo to the same
kind of circumstance and we've seen
these kind of situations go on for hours
and hours at end which is really
traumatic for the kid and what are they
learning in those hours that they're
basically being Behind Closed Doors by
themselves
so it it seeks to tighten that up and
then the other thing that we've seen and
it's interesting because we've seen
facilities do this well and we've seen
them do it poorly is basically dragging
a kid out of their program putting them
in a room that might be called a quiet
room or a contemplation area or some
other euphemism and they might be able
to staff member but the staff is
blocking the door not engaging with the
child and in some cases we've gotten
reports that kids are actually like the
staff when the child tries to engage
with them they're demeaning them they're
like criticizing them they're saying
mean things about their family about the
child you know it's not a therapeutic
intervention yet we've also seen
facilities that we've in that we've
monitored
have kids where they actually recognize
when the child's behavior is getting a
bit out of control they've worked with
the child to help them recognize this
themselves they have a separate space
that a child can go to that's sort of
like a happy calming space and they have
staff in there that use a behavior plan
to work with the child for kids with
autism we've seen rooms like this that
have like a swing it's kind of like a
hammock that they feel safe in and can
get some movement and calm down others
have like beanbag chairs and are kind of
cozy where kids can voluntarily take
advantage of an opportunity to learn a
skill the skill is no one to need no one
to ask for a break
and then be able to have someone on the
other side who's processing with you
like what happened so someone on the
other side working with the child to
help them figure out what happened and
then get them back in the classroom
some of these places will be monitored
that don't do that we've we've heard
from kids who have slept overnight how
dangerous are you when you're sleeping
overnight you know where's the present
danger there and you're separated from
your peers and you're in a separate
space that's hard walls nothing on them
and you're sleeping there overnight
because you swore at staff
so
anyway I'm happy to take other questions
which hopefully I can answer more
eloquently than I did when I started
representative ball thank you chairman
Pearson hi good to see you again nice to
see you
um going back to when you read that
definition from the RSA I think it was
126u
I
I didn't think I heard the word
discipline
so because with the
restraint was the first thing that the
law prohibited right and then seclusion
was added so the the sections don't add
they they don't align perfectly well so
in the seclusion portion of the bill
they separate out those two features so
when you see like the restraint part
um restraints shall not be used
explicitly or implicitly as a punishment
for the behavior of the child just above
it it says restraints shall only be used
in a school or facility to ensure the
immediate physical safety of persons
when there is a substantial and imminent
risk of serious bodily harm so in with
the restraint they separate you know
it's in the same section but they broke
it into two they mean your predecessors
probably unless you're around then broke
it into two separate Roman numeral
paragraphs so I suppose you could break
paragraphs I I don't know that that's
necessary though to convey
what we're trying to convey here it's
just a different way that they wrote it
I don't think it's inconsistent
we're trying to mirror like that
definition but I thought you said
everything that is written without the
word discipline because I'm going back
to that idea that that discipline is
teaching all those skills so why would
we want to say we're going to
um
not use it I understand that we're then
turning around and saying we are going
to use it but I guess I'm just saying
why don't we just leave it as punishment
and take out the or discipline so
seclusion and seclusion and restraint
are emergency responses they're not
disciplined they're not punishment right
that's what they're like that's but what
we but we've received information that
suggests that some schools and
Facilities use it like as a threat or as
discipline and that's just inappropriate
and that's why our law has even since
2014 when we added the prohibition
against useless occlusion included
language saying that it cannot be used
as punishment or discipline the only the
objective here was just to mirror the
language that we use in Restraint with
restraint to avoid confusion and make it
really if it wasn't clear before
this is not appropriately used as
punishment or discipline does that help
it does
um
it does I guess I'm just stuck on that
word because it still implies to me that
that is a positive and um that what is a
positive discipline
is used I mean if those I guess my
concern is that I'm wondering if these
other facilities are using it wrong
they're not understanding the difference
between the two because clearly some of
the things they're doing is that is not
disciplineable that is punishment well
what the other what the facilities are
doing is not using seclusion because
what this bill says is that if you have
a child you're working on a plan with
them and they voluntarily go to like a
sensory room for example with staff
that's not seclusion
so those facilities are using this the
separation of the child in a way that's
voluntary to the child and it's done in
a therapeutic way
so and also what this bill would do is
say you know what even if you're not
sending the kid to a therapeutic
separate room but you're having them in
a room with another staff member and
it's just a separate room that as long
as that staff member is engaging there
in a therapeutic manner with that child
that that would not be considered
seclusion
so so the the reason that's important is
because it allows for the situation
where as Senator alschilder
intimated sometimes these are really
quick situations so if a child's
behavior is unexpected quickly quick out
a teacher can take the child out of the
room go in another room with them and
then help them to process what's going
on and we're not going to call that
seclusion but if it's but what it seeks
to get at though is If instead the child
is removed to a separate room in a
facility and and there's nothing there
for the child and the person refuses to
interact with them and there is no
Behavior plan or they demean them
because that's not therapeutic that
would be considered seclusion
representative Greg
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
being here and explaining this so what
I'm I just want to make sure that I'm
understanding because I think there's
some confusion about the never used and
then may use so the only reason that
we're saying never is
because it's like that quick thing so
we're you're never able to just throw
the kid in a closet and walk away it has
to be explicitly or implicit has to be
used with something else so if there's
the immediate response we need to remove
them for just a minute let them cool
down but a staff is staying nearby
um because we're trying to prevent
somebody from just doing this and just
walking away or kind of locking them in
and forgetting them is that correct is
that why the language reads that way but
I think it's it's also it's important to
read the next sentence absolutely right
because it says you know when you may
use it right because really this is an
emergency response right and that's and
and so the intent here is to make it
clear that it's to Define what seclusion
is and then which is and and Define what
that emergency response could could look
like and but make it clear that you know
you're limited to using this kind of
emergency response to certain situations
child poses a substantial and imminent
risk of physical harm to others perfect
thank you
representative DeSimone
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I'm still struggling
with the word never now according to the
definition of never it is that no time
in the past or future
on no occasion not ever
so if you use the word never
in that first sentence and then go to
the next one and say but if you want to
you can
I I'm struggling with that I I I just
can't get it can you help my struggle
I'll try to help your struggle
like I said it's I mean one thing
you could do is reverse the order of
those sentences maybe that would help I
think those two sentences are still
there which basically lets you know that
seclusion may only be used similarly to
the the restraint though right the
restraint portion of this it's all in
the same section
um when it was drafted they just the
maybe you were here actually
um it was just separated out into two
separate paragraphs I think the the
outcome is basically the same however
um and I think the intent here was
um to really make it clear
using the same language that we use for
restraint it wasn't to make just it
wasn't it it was basically to make it
mirror that restraint language so that
it's abundantly clear there was a
feeling that seclusion the way it reads
now may not be used as a form of
punishment or discipline wasn't strong
enough language
so that's why it was put in but but if I
mean it could be just you could you
could just add a Roman and and switch
the order if that would be more
comfortable I would really like to move
this hearing along I'm looking at what's
on the books now in the book that it's
in and you can have a version of that by
looking at your bill and seeing the
strikeout right I think as lsrs in 2021
and I checked the supplements to make
sure
etc etc
um
it made sense because the word May
is is not a mandatory word it's a
permissive word I think if the first two
sentences were slightly reworded we
would solve this problem and we can move
along yeah because everything else in
here I've been able to find on the books
already right that's the only change and
if our problem is with that only thing
right there I think a very simple little
patch job could be done could we move on
obviously I would defer to the sponsor
but I think I think it personally if you
want to just have a romance
yeah I don't think it's a problem either
this is a great solution the non-pro
okay thank you so much that resolves my
struggle thank you good thank you
grammatically correct it wasn't even in
the book I got for Christmas that's why
we have to come over there thank you so
much everyone thank you counselor
um Holly Stevens Counselor come forward
Nami New Hampshire we've got your hand
out already
good morning chairman Pearson members of
the committee my name is Holly Stevens
I'm the director of public policy for
Nami New Hampshire Nami is a non-profit
Grassroots organization whose mission is
to improve the lives of all people
impacted by mental illness and suicide
through support education and advocacy
on behalf of Nami New Hampshire I'm here
today in support of Senate Bill 179 as
amended by the Senate
um also just wanted to point out that
you know per Nami National we also adopt
a lot of their own policy positions but
we also believe that no one should be
subjected to practices that worsen
Mental Health
seclusion worsens mental health when it
is used
inappropriately as a punishment or a
form of discipline when it's used to
keep people safe then that's a pro and
an appropriate use of seclusion I will
keep my remarks brief you've already
heard that this is trauma it causes
trauma in the kids you have my written
testimony as well as a policy paper
um that came out from Nami National I
did email that to you because there's a
lot of hyperlinks in that that lead to
different researches research that's
been done on how this is trauma and I
but I did also want to go back to
the never and then going on further to
something else
never is qualified by
the punishment or discipline aspect of
it
so if it's not being used as a
punishment or discipline then it is
permissible
so the never is being qualified by those
two words at the end of the sentence
um and I just you know since you have
heard a lot of testimony about this I
just wanted to recount you know my own
experience at Hampstead Hospital where I
worked for two years prior to going to
law school
and I worked with a lot with this little
boy who was much like a jumping bean and
every time we'd go downstairs to do
school he would start running from table
to table on the tops of them he would
run down the halls and I would have to
chase after him
and I will tell you there were times
that I became so frustrated I would have
loved to been able to put him in our
quiet room and say
block the door and this is where we're
due in school
but that wasn't appropriate it wasn't
appropriate because he wasn't being
unsafe
he knew how to jump from table to table
very safely
so I just leave you with that that you
know there are situations where staff
get frustrated and it'd be much easier
for me to have been able to contain him
but it would have been very
inappropriate
so um today Nami New Hampshire urges
this committee to take a strong look at
this bill if you have concerns about the
language that you think need to be fixed
certainly the stakeholders here are
amendable to that but we do support the
Senate bill as amended and I will take
any questions that you have I'm going to
ask this question of all the lawyers
coming
do you see the bill as presented to us
propose any linguistic problems in the
juxtaposition of it may not be and it
may only be do you see any legal
difficulty with the bill as presented to
us no and the reason for that chairman
Pearson is because that first sentence
says shall never be used explicitly or
implicitly implicitly as punishment or
discipline so never is qualified by the
punishment and the discipline aspect of
that
thank you thank you
Gen X called Kristen Evans from Able New
Hampshire
um if you could be very brief please but
especially speak to that point I just
mentioned about the first two lines
lines four and five if there's any legal
opinion
um that are you a lawyer no then you can
skip that part okay thank you I get to
do it because I get the law book I
appreciate it uh Dear honorable chairman
and members of the committee thank you
for the opportunity to testify in
support of SB 179 for the record my name
is Kristen Evans and I am the director
of policy for able New Hampshire able is
New Hampshire's only disability Justice
organization and we advocate for the
civil and human rights of children and
adults with disability I will keep my
testimony brief you have my written
testimony in front of you it was passed
out earlier I would like to express our
strong support for SB 179 as an
organization dedicated to advancing the
rights and dignity of individuals with
disabilities we believe that the use of
seclusion is harmful and inhumane
practice that must be banned research
has shown that seclusion is often used
disproportionately on children with
disabilities particularly those with
autism and other developmental disorders
according to a 2019 report by the
national disability rights Network
children with disabilities are
overrepresented in seclusion and
restraints include incidents in school
with one study finding that they
accounted for 71 percent of such
incidences the passage of SB 179 would
be a significant step towards promoting
the safety and well-being of children
with disabilities in schools and
treatment facilities we urge lawmakers
to support this important legislation
and prioritize the rights and dignity of
all children
thank you thank you any questions
saying none thank you
and now Tessa Smith has signed up to
speak Tessa first of all you a lawyer
you may be seated
I'm a parent if that helps that
qualifies all right
um my name is Tessa Smith I live in
Loudon New Hampshire I have two sons
that are 12 and 9 that are complete
opposites my older son loves sports and
my younger son loves to sing and dance
um this bill affects my family
especially my little Sour Patch kiddo
Nico because Nico has autism he attends
fourth grade at Loudoun Elementary in a
regular classroom but uses the quiet
room daily as we know now the quiet room
is also known as the seclusion room my
thought on what a quiet room was and
what I was mostly shown was and mostly
empty classroom with a couple chairs a
little bit of artwork on the
um on the walls unfortunately
um
that's not the case his quiet room is a
white padded room with gym pads on the
walls much like in an institution
um my son uses this room daily
the most recent use of this was this
past week on Wednesday when my
nine-year-old son was forced to spend
hours guarded by his para who's
intimidating by the way but lovely until
he could calm down he was put in this
room for taking things off the teacher's
desk and gesturing a fist he couldn't
calm down enough in time to go home on
the school bus so they kept him there in
that quiet room until I could come get
him unfortunately that was also the day
where I didn't have my vehicle so I had
to call every single family member I
know and find a way for him to get home
um thankfully my sister was only 25
minutes away and so he continued to
spend the rest of the day in that room
until she was able to pick him up
um I support this bill because having a
co-regular in the room with him which he
has someone check on him but for the
most part it's just guarded by the
parent in the room
um would allow him to be able to access
skills and coping mechanisms that he has
that he can't access himself obviously
with autism it's really hard to regulate
yourself so having someone in there and
just checking on him at 30 minute
interval Max would be able to access
those skills and help him calm down to
their standard I do want to ask for some
clarification
um in that first section under u5
section one
my issue with that is the last three
words danger has dissipated
to me I would assume that meant
something violent or dangerous but to
them it can be as simple as gesturing a
fist and saying I don't want to go with
you is when he gets removed to the quiet
room so I didn't know if there was a
possibility for clarification
the
statutes as presently in the books
it speaks of imminent risk of physical
harm to the child or others
dot dot dot until that danger is
dissipated to me that last Clause
um
goes with what precedes it it speaks of
physical harm to the child and others
the child advocate is going to be
speaking next and she may wish to
address uh that
but it it it it seems to go together as
a piece in my reading
but I hear your concern it could be
twisted perhaps yes it's kind of
subjective whereas gesturing a fist to
me wouldn't be imminent danger to
himself or others it can be constituted
as that because it is a physically
violent gesture
um I did have one more clarification on
the section with the preference order
for the adults which is the next page
under a it says a trusted adult selected
by the child
um as it currently stands that doesn't
specify whether they have training or
not
so that would be interesting to know
whether or not they're required to have
training or Joe Schmo can be picked and
not know how to deal with an unruly
child specifically
thank you we'll ask that question too
she has a question thank you would you
take any questions yes representative
Grossman with a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
coming and present and giving your
testimony
um how does this affect your son
he hates it
um he tells me every day that he wants
to lock himself in the room so that we
can't force him to go to school anymore
and unfortunately that's just another
room great that it has video games but
it's not great that he has to sit there
and want to stay home and you know use
every threat in the book I mean I've had
dcyf at my house numerous times because
he knows what he can say to get out of
schoolwork to not have to go because he
goes to that quiet room I've had the
school psychologist in an IEP meeting
say that oh no we can't break up the day
into intervals to try and get him back
up into the classroom we need to leave
him in that room until he has no more
Behavior so that he can return to that
and um unfortunately I've been in
different districts where that room
instead of being padded was a closet
um an actual closet like concrete walls
in the Manchester District so thankfully
it's now bigger and padded but you know
it's the same situation where he's been
there since four page four he's used
this quiet Ramon he's now nine he's it's
very well familiar with the quiet room
representative Nelson
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um my question to you is how
um with with this weekly occurrence how
is it affecting his uh ability to keep
up with the education
process
so unfortunately he does have some
learning issues where he is behind in
his peers but when he's in the classroom
for example right before we moved to
Loudon we were in the Raymond school
district and they didn't use a quiet
room
um he progressed from not really
participating in the classroom to
learning how to carry over the one which
I couldn't teach him
um learning how to read we found out
that he memorized his books so that's
why his reading level is better than
what we thought it was because he has
this neat trick where he hears one book
one time and he has it completely
memorized so the trick is to keep up
with him but he has his little niches
that you get to know and he makes so
much progress when he's actually in the
classrooms but unfortunately he has
learned since for on that if he has
these behaviors especially if he flops
on the ground or threatens to flip a
table it's mostly threats you know but
unfortunately that's when he gets put in
the quiet room and he tends to make a
lot less progress um this year he's made
a lot of progress in reading but for the
most part has stayed pretty
significantly behind
thank you
thank you for your testimony appreciate
that
thank you
and the chair now calls uh Cassandra
Sanchez Office of the child advocate
good morning Mr chairman and Steve
members of the children family law
committee for the record Cassandra
Sanchez child advocate for the State of
New Hampshire
so as you heard much testimony before me
indicating the Trump traumatizing
effects of seclusion I will not get too
deep into that topic for you I will
focus a bit though on the co-regulation
pieces I want to ensure that that is
understood by the committee
I also provided you a letter here from
Katie Peg NADA she is a licensed
clinical mental health counselor she has
worked with my office in reviewing this
the Senate Bill she has an expertise in
mental health clinical mental health
Counseling of children as well as
consultation in the schools so she
currently provides consultation to
schools around how to manage different
behaviors in a way that is trauma
informed and is less impactful to the
children
and so a brief section I'm going to read
here for you from her letters when a
child is dysregulated is the job of an
adult who is responsible for the child
to emit safety in order for the child's
nervous system
to neurosep safety which opens the
pathways to regulation adults he met
safety through being in social
engagement State and utilizing calm
verbal and non-verbal communication
strategies this is what we call
co-regulation and so in speaking about
as was the question prior was about
these adults in order and when we're
looking at a co-regulator it's not
necessarily a skill set the mtss
training that is is in the schools is
being expanded in the schools can cover
this but it's truly just understanding
trauma-informed care which is meeting a
child where they're at and so a person
without training could actually be more
who has a close relationship to the
child could actually be more impactful
in these situations than somebody who is
trained in therapeutic techniques
because it's about being that calm body
getting to the child's level trying to
engage with them and and at times that
engagement could just be offering a
listening ear and that child may just be
screaming about what they're going
through and saying yes I understand
that's difficult and so that doesn't
take a lot of training and that's one of
the benefits of having this this
co-regulation model is that we're not
asking the schools to employ additional
professionals that have specific
training and techniques to be able to do
this we're asking the school to engage
in the mtss which is being offered to
them to have a general understanding of
trauma-informed care which we are asking
of all School professionals at this
point across the state and then we are
asking those people to understand that
the child is in crisis and understand
that they just need a calm person to
absorb their emotions in that moment and
enough where they they are no longer an
imminent risk of harm to themselves or
somebody else
and so that that's a piece for me that
was really critical in taking a look at
improving the use of seclusion because
they do understand there are programs
that do use seclusion in this state
specifically because of the high needs
of the children that they serve and it's
ensuring that they're only using it when
they're when they have tried every other
opportunity to de-escalate that child
they've tried the verbal techniques
they've tried to engage with them in
this way and absorb their emotions
they've tried to let them Express their
emotions without intervention for a
moment and then they're getting to the
point where they're saying this child is
really a danger they're either attacking
staff or we have a lot of children
especially on the autism spectrum that
will be begin self-harming themselves
they may sit in a wall and start banging
their head aggressively and so it's
getting them away from that into a place
that has softer materials around them
and so there is some of the programs
that we work with do have the ability to
use seclusion safely and minimally only
when absolutely necessary and we're
trying to ensure that continues as you
heard before me I believe it was Karen
Rosenberg from the DRC that share that
we do understand that there are schools
and Facilities that find loopholes to
this and so they may have an adult sit
in a room with a child but that adult's
not interacting with a child they're not
attempting to co-regulate they're just
watching a child and so what this writes
in with the co-regulation is they can
sit there and watch the child for 30
minutes but after 30 minutes it is
within their role to either themselves
or bring somebody else in who's actually
going to interact with that child and
and try to help them regulate and what
we know about about co-regulation is
that for children with
attachment issues which unfortunately we
see with a lot of children with trauma
histories and those who've been removed
from their home settings they do not
have the ability to learn regulation on
their own in the time that children do
with healthy attachments so when
children have healthy attachments they
should be able to self-regulate around
adolescence they need support in their
younger years and in adolescence they
they start to learn about themselves and
understand what it takes to help calm
themselves down children with complex
trauma that does not happen in that time
frame so what we know is that they need
the support of these co-regulators to
learn how to self-regulate and so over
time this intervention by the
co-regulator will actually teach them
how to be able to do this on their own
and then they will be able to in in
young adulthood and later in adulthood
be able to regulate on their own and
have better mental health outcomes and
overall health outcomes as we understand
the aces right this is all tied to Aces
the only other question I think we have
is your
legal analysis of lines four and five on
page one I can save you some time I'm
not an attorney
I'll take anybody I'm a social worker in
your social worker um
you see no difficulty in Your Capacity
as a social worker
between
those two lines uh lines four and five
seclusion may not be used
but it may only be used yes so for I I
stand firmly in the same understanding
that Holly shared with us in that that
never is tied to explicitly to
punishment and discipline so because of
that language I do not see an issue with
it but as as some had requested the
separation out and potentially shifting
them in a different order so it is more
clearly aligned I I would be in
agreement and in support
the people who wrote the law that's
currently on the books had no difficulty
with it
everything's the two together but okay
thank you any questions for the child
advocate representative Nelson thank you
Mr chairman it's just a quick one I mean
I um I want to ask you the same question
that I asked earlier
um how did you determine or how did your
group or people determine
um that the checking of the child at
regular intervals not to exceed 30
minutes yes so that that actually I
worked very closely with the licensed
mental health counselor on specifically
because taking a look at what is the
extensive period understanding that it
may take time for especially in a school
setting where she does consultation in
schools it may take time to get the
preferred adult to be available for the
child
um if they're a classroom teacher or if
they're a janitor in another part of the
school it may take time so how much time
is it that a child could be left and
that the trauma impact is not going to
greatly affect their mental health and
their progress in life and so it was
determined that a 30-minute interval is
reasonable for a child to attempt to
self-regulate and anything beyond that
could be more damaging to their Mental
Health
all right just a follow-up please so hi
thank you um so if the child let's say
the child is in the room
for an hour and a half would that mean
that the only requirement would be that
there would be like
three check-ins
would the child be would the child
potentially be left alone
for long like periods of 29 minutes
and then another 29 minutes is that
possible I mean I'm just trying to
sure make sure that so that should be
only if there is
um seclusion by by current definition
right we were talking about a children
being imminent danger to themselves or
somebody else because these other
removals from a classroom to address
Behavior should accompany an adult and
so it really it makes it so that this is
for those
instances where there is formal
seclusion that is used by the current
law where a child may have been for
instance in a facility they may have
been in a milieu and they started to
attack a child nearby them and so they
are removed and the staff is trying to
help de-escalate and in the process the
staff de-escalating the child is now
attacking the staff and is is aggressive
towards the staff and so at that point
they may use formal seclusion in which
they would have the child in the room my
understanding of them most of the way in
which most of the facilities in the
state operate is that if they have a
child in seclusion in that room
they have an adult outside of the door
so the door may be locked or maybe held
by an adult but the adult is outside the
room watching for the child so if the
child is able to settle prior to that 30
minute time period
that child is then released from the
room by the staff member because they
are watching and so what this is saying
is that if they're watching and this
child is not able to regulate in that
way then the staff is to intervene as
opposed to there are times where we have
seen seclusions at last beyond 30
minutes because a child isn't able to
regulate on their own and they may be
escalating in their behavior as they
stay there and so this is ensuring that
there is an adult that will intervene
even if they're still in a heightened
state
to attempt that opportunity and for some
they may have that one one touch point
with a staff member that may not be
enough for them to regulate so that
staff member may have to come back
outside that door and at that point
the hope is that they would then find
somebody I've attempted to regulate with
this child they're not taking to me so
I'm going to find another staff member
to come in and do that the next
regulation with the child thank you I
appreciate that I was just trying to
wrap my head around that any other
questions for the child Advocates seeing
none thank you so much
now we have a question before the
committee
if you really think
that we've got to have an amendment
to break out more explicitly lines four
and five
that'll be one choice the other is
um
the word only it may only it modifies by
punishment and discipline only
the bill is good as it is and we can
execute those are your two choices so
I'd like to see a show of hands how many
of you really want
us to wait and those of you putting your
hands up will be responsible for helping
the amendment to be written put your
hand up
how many of you think it's good to go
and we can get this thing to the floor
of the house and to the governor it
looks pretty good to me
so
this
go ahead well not yet but thank you
this ends the hearing on Senate Bill 179
and Begins the exact session on Senate
Bill 179 and the chair
um calls on gosh representative Grossman
for most
thank you Mr chairman I make a motion
um
for OTP SB 179 and do I have a second
representative long also a co-sponsor
any further discussion
we have before us
Senate Bill 179 the motion is ought to
pass moved by representative Grossman
seconded by representative long relative
to eliminating the use of seclusion as a
form of punishment or discipline on
children schools or tree and treatment
facilities and the clerk may call the
role please
[Music]
representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
Seidel yes representative Grossman yes
representative Levesque is not here
representative Petrino yes
representative Perez
yes representative Greg yes
representative Moulton is not here
representative Raymond yes that would be
14 years and two absence any
any objection to
consent
any objection to representative Grossman
writing the report no
this concludes the executive session on
179 and I have late breaking news from
Concord New Hampshire
the committee report on Senate Bill 206
on corporal punishment past 14-0 and is
going to consent senator
expected very good thank you thank you
Mr chairman that that is good news
um I think you heard testimony that um
the oversight uh Commission on
children's services dealt with this
issue we were quite frankly horrified
when we were notified of the
um the audit that had been done by
um a performance audit that had been
done at the Nashua Children's Home and
the issue of seclusion came up so we
knew we had to do something and and
Senator alt Schiller
put in legislation and after the
children's oversight Services discussed
this
um
our child advocate was there and she
said I think we need to fine-tune this a
little bit and that afternoon she had
worked with the disability rights Center
and had language for an amendment which
was adopted
um on the floor and so hopefully
everyone agreed I think they did so
um let's get this one going to the
governor's office and do you know that
that same facility in Nashville is the
subject of an hour and a half hearing
before DHHS oversight committee which I
chair yes I I was aware of that we were
coming at it from a number of angles
and now Senator would you introduce
Senate Bill 43 thank you Mr chairman and
good morning again for the record
um my my name is uh Sharon Carson I have
the pleasure of representing Senate
District 14 comprising the towns of
Londonderry Hudson and Auburn and I have
for your consideration this morning
Senate Bill 43 relative to A needs
assessment for juvenile minors who are
residents of the State of New Hampshire
um Mr chairman Senate Bill 43 is just a
cleanup of a mistake that had been made
in Senate bill 94.
um as has been heard repeatedly in
discussing the sysc debate dcyf now does
a strengths and A needs assessment on
youth before they go to court on
delinquency charges we use that to make
recommendations to divert kids from
court and towards services and it's
working great with a 7 to 72 percent of
kids being diverted
um we have one on unanticipated issue I
think um Mr chairman uh most of you
should know this bill came at the
request of the Department of Health and
Human Services
um they've run into a problem
um along the border communities Senate
Bill 94 required assessments for all
youth no matter from what state they
came from but we only provide services
to kids from New Hampshire this means we
end up utilizing staff time and
resources doing assessments for kids
from mass mostly Vermont and Maine who
can't actually engage in the recommended
services
these are most typically shoplifting
charges from the Salem Mall that results
in a fine all the bill does is make
clear that the assessment process is
intended for New Hampshire youths so at
this point Mr chair I will end my
testimony and I will try to answer any
question
I have a question the use of the word
resident in line nine I've got a note
saying what is the definition of that in
line nine and also line four
well I think when we talk I know this
this can be a touchy issue
um when it comes to voting but it's my
understand that Resident means that they
actually live here in New Hampshire as
you know children
um these youths they're 18 years and
Below well below the age of 18 they're
considered to be minors they live with
adults so they actually have to live
here in New Hampshire
that's my understanding of what the term
residence means is that defined in
statute anywhere Mr chairman I don't
want to say it is because I'm not sure
um and I don't want to give you folks
bad information but I would hope that
for the purpose of this statute it is
already in uh let's in statute
representative DeSimone
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question
um back to the uh word resident
we have boarding schools
if a child is living at the boarding
school
is that child a resident of the State of
New Hampshire
um representative I I'm not going to
answer that question because I'm not
sure and again I don't want to give you
bad information but someone is here from
the Department who hopefully will be
able to answer that question for you
thank you thank you any other questions
for the senator
seeing none um
just
Mr
would you write a note for my next eye
exam please I literally have a lack of
peripheral vision I can see the senator
very well representative Bickford for
your question uh thank you Mr chair
thank you Senator thank you my my
I'm trying to understand uh what's
happened I know uh
uh in my
community area there's no more any
diversion that it seems to have
disappeared and someone said well it's
gone it's being done through the state
now and so I've lost a little track of
the process
of of this and so
what happens
to the children
um that say do live over the Border but
are coming up here and committing some
form of crime
um
so do they still go to the court system
in New Hampshire or
thank you for the question
representative it's my understanding
they do because they're held responsible
it's just when we talk about
um
uh the diversion process because our our
hands are really tied we can't force
someone who lives in another state to
come back here to New Hampshire for
whatever treatment that the court has
outlined for them and that's where the
problem is so that's why we're looking
to change it to just be children that
live here in New Hampshire I would hope
that when a child from out of state
commits a crime here in New Hampshire
that they work with those uh with that
other state to either
um with whatever recommendations they
have it's just that we are spending our
time and resources on assessing these
kids when we really at the end of the
day
don't really have that kind of control
over them to get them into the types of
treatment that we think are would be
appropriate for them rather than some
sort of punitive punishment thank you
you're welcome
anyone else
representative panic
I almost see this as a problem
because if
we're aboard a state I live on the
border
and if I see them coming over to our
town in tearing it all up
and they get arrested in our town and
they have to go to the Salem courts
and we're not we can't do anything
we're not correcting the problem now
I thank you for the question and I'm
trying to think of what would be an
appropriate answer it's not that these
children are not being held responsible
there it's the fact that we're going to
go through this process of assessing
these children
um as a way of trying to divert them out
of the system I think everyone in this
room knows about informed trauma there's
underlying reasons why kids are acting
out and sometimes it's better to divert
them into some sort of Mental Health
Care rather than putting them in some
sort of facility I think it also depends
upon the type of crime that has been
committed
um but I
I think I've answered your question
we're what we've done here in New
Hampshire is we've really tried to keep
children out of the criminal justice
system because I think Mo everyone in
this room realizes oftentimes when these
kids come into contact if you don't get
to the root of the problem they're going
to keep coming back over and over and
over again and what you really want to
do is stop that so you really want to
get to the root of the problem I'm not
saying that we shouldn't do this with
kids that commit crimes here it's just
that we can't enforce that when they go
back home and that's really what the
Crux of the problem is
representative DeSimone
thank you Mr chairman and just to back
up what Senator Carson had to say
um
especially in Border towns when a youth
does break the law and they go to court
the courts will tell them there is a
diversion agency
that will accept your child who lives
out of state
and they can do the diversion
or they can pay this penalty
so the court does
assess a penalty or the crime
but they offer now we can't again as
Senator Carson said we cannot force them
but the agency that
um I'm on the board for we have accepted
many young people from Haverhill
Lawrence Lowell and they have come in
and done challenge courses and thus and
so so it can happen but as she said it's
an interstate thing
thank you
my question is what does this leave
empty now if the arresting agency
contemplates the initiation of Court
proceedings prior to filing a
delinquency petition that's what we have
now but if we restrict it by saying
involving a resident minor
I'm just wondering what does the
arresting agency of somebody
who came over and did an expensive Smash
and grab in a jewelry store just over
the border from Vermont what is the
arresting agency get to do now or if
should this pass well I thank you Mr
chairman I would hope that they would
um talk with the authorities where this
child is from and they can core
hopefully coordinate something where the
child is going to be held responsible
for what they did in New Hampshire but
realizing that it might not be good for
the child if if the crime was serious
enough to be held here in New Hampshire
that maybe there's something that they
could do
in the state where they came from I'm
wondering if um going forward after we
passed this perhaps this would be a good
conversation with law enforcement
agencies who live in Border towns or or
are State Police troops that are on
Border towns
what problems do you see maybe you've
done that I don't know
well thank you again for the question I
think any time that you can involve
everyone
that is in contact with a child who is
in trouble the better off that child is
going to be to get the type of help and
treatment they they really need to have
but I think they also need to be made
aware of the fact that their actions
have consequences and I and again I I
strongly believe in our court system
that they work very very hard to do the
right thing for these kids and so this
bill simply just says look we're we
can't really do these types of
assessment on kids from out of state
unless they're actually being held I
mean oftentimes if it's a shoplifting
crime they're charged here in New
Hampshire and then they go home
how are you going to make them come back
for that assessment
because usually they just let them go
so the many people from out of state
that the representative references that
number presumably is going to shrink
considerably now
Mr chairman I don't want to make that
kind of assumption I just go on the fact
of that when we're dealing with children
from New Hampshire as the department had
stated we've seen a 72 percent drop in
the number of kids that are going into
the system and the diversion that we are
using is working very very well
okay any further questions for the
senator I'm yes representative DeSimone
thank you Mr chairman just to clarify
when diversion agencies in this state
are dealing with in-state children
the fees are much different than when
you're dealing with an out-of-state
child
so that's the difference and that's how
diversion agencies work and we went from
needing 144 beds
to needing 12 to 18 beds
anything else
thank you Senator thank you Mr chairman
and I will see you all at one o'clock
yeah
you get frequent flyer miles
Senator Whitley got some recently
in my other committee so
yeah
chair recognizes Beth magnesium from
dcyf and I got the name wrong didn't I
that was quite all right Mr chair it's
Beth margison
Marge like you wrote yes margison so uh
thank you very much uh chair pear
Pearson chair of Vice chair long and all
members of the committee
um the division is here to support the
bill obviously because we asked Senator
Carson if she would gracefully sponsor
this bill for us and I don't really need
to add anything else to what she said
other than to reiterate um or maybe
perhaps uh get a little bit deeper on
the diversion aspect of this so this is
so what happens is is that
um children from out of state are still
subject to you know the process of you
know if it's a shoplifting restitution
and and whatnot it's what we want to do
for in-state children is to allow them
to participate in a diversion program we
obviously have no jurisdiction over
children who reside out of state so we
just need to make sure that we're
spending our resources and
um on children who reside in state
representative long thank you Mr
chairman uh the is there a definition of
a resident minor I mean I'm thinking of
Summer Camps I'm thinking of boarding
schools
um thank you for the question
representative not that I'm aware of I
mean it's just a suit it's just the
underpinning of the statute 169b because
it's for children it's for children who
reside who are new in New Hampshire so
it's it's implicit in the statute that
uh 169 B applies to children who are New
Hampshire residents
okay thank you
representative Bickford
thank you Mr chairman thank you
um
what happens when you've gone through
the process of an assessment with a
resident child and then they moved to
Massachusetts
um I think I
I think
um
oftentimes the by the time they may have
moved we may have been done with their
diversion process
um and then perhaps and if not perhaps a
referral can be made but I actually
really don't know that's just my guess
to be honest thank you
so
this does not really change
the fact that people from New Hampshire
shall be referred
for needs assessments already right here
in the Lubbock that is correct what it's
doing is those four words in both face
italics it is restricting it and the
only reason I can think of is to save
some money so we can put our resources
more to our own people yes yes it is you
know it utilize utilizing staff
resources not that we don't care about
out-of-state children as I'm sure all of
you care about Aid of State children but
you know our responsibility is to
in-state is to New Hampshire residents
so utilizing our staff resources and
obviously you know there is a behavioral
and and mental health provider shortage
in the in the state so actually being
able to Target this very valuable
assessment tool
um so that it's only used on New
Hampshire children is is quite quite
impactful to your knowledge
um given granted the
significant shortage of resource
Personnel are we seeing this in that
program presently if a child is arrested
and is referred for A needs assessment
are we seeing a backlog you know we'll
do your needs assessment but you got to
wait two months because we don't have
enough people
I don't believe so in Juvenile Justice
I'm not really sure if we contract with
an outside agency to do it I don't know
that
um I don't know about the backlogs on
that okay thank you any questions
for Beth marcheson
thank you very much you always ask very
good questions I wish I knew more of the
answer sometimes thank you keep coming
back we all learn together well that is
it and I now close the hearing on Senate
Bill 43 and just a straw poll
um
how many of you think this bill needs
more work versus how many of you think
it's good to go
for exacting how many needs more work
hands up
how many we're good to go on exact game
okay I see
just about everybody so I now open I
close the hearing on sb43 if I didn't
just and I opened the exec session on
the Senate bill 43.
and
um
I haven't put the question yet you made
it
any others out there that belong to us
nope you didn't see anybody else no okay
just want to give them a shot
all right
um
who would like to move
ought to pass and write
the wonderful committee report
not sold in stores soon to be a movie is
that a hand saying yes
and what is your emotion
uh
you move
ought to pass
you do and it's very and I see
representative Perez
seconding it
well everybody gets return eventually
you know
any further discussion
anybody want to go to lunch in three
minutes
okay so when the clerk is ready please
call the roll the motion is with
representative Grossman in the room for
this motion Senate Bill 43 ought to pass
moved by representative Panic second by
representative Perez
the bill is relative to needs assessment
for juvenile miners who are residents of
New Hampshire
chairman call the rule
chairman Pearson yes
representative long yes representative
DeSimone yes representative Big Fish yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon
representative ball
representative Panic yes representative
Seidel yes representative Grossman yes
representative Levesque I believe is
absent
representative Petrino will be voting
yes representative Perez
representative Greg yes representative
Moulton is absent representative Raymond
yes 14-0 were too absence and ought to
pass and any objection to going on to
consent
seeing none thank you a couple of
announcements before we break for lunch
we will be back at one o'clock and about
2 15 the the committee Services is going
to do a little bit of room Readjustment
we are inviting the Judiciary Committee
and others who are interested in the
practices of the Judiciary we've had
several bills that we tabled because we
agreed that some of the bills have some
good points to them but some of them
evidence not enough knowledge of how the
Judiciary works so from 2 30
on we will be having the first of what
may be several continuing education
events so we can learn more about how
the court system works
I received from the clerk of the house
four Senate bills that crossed over and
were assigned to this committee we will
have done all four of these today I have
no further bills but the Senate is still
senating so there may be more we will
not meet next Tuesday because we have
nothing other nothing to meet about but
as soon as I start getting additional
bills I'll let you know that I have and
what their numbers are and I'll try to
group them so we don't come up for an
hour and a half and have to go back home
again but we'll try to group them so
that we'll make a day of it I think most
people like that so there we go and oh
I've also heard from
the powers that be that the rule is
still
you may have we may have water in the
room but we've got to take our food and
beverages other than water elsewhere and
that doesn't mean another room like this
one and I've been guilty of that so when
that came down I said I got to pass this
along just in case that I brought a
sandwich and a beverage and I'm going
down to the cafeteria to have it so just
to just a reminder of what we were told
but I think I know I forgot so there we
go have a good lunch
I asked our people at dcyf how we Define
Resident and we use the definition of
resident in the doe statutes just so
since there are questions of it
okay could you get that for us and send
it our way I certainly canceled thank
you all right thanks
are you looking for the definition now
because she's going to write the blurb
and if you could get it to her fairly
quickly we could incorporate it in her
committee report otherwise we're going
to be challenged somebody will pull the
bill off consent and it's a mess so if
you can get that for her that'll be
really helpful
foreign
thank you
we
have two of Senator Carson's two bills
presented to us
that have already gone on to consent
today
and here we are at the one o'clock hour
seeing will she score the hat-trick
you framed that so well ever consider
politics
no they get paid better
open the hearing on
the Senate Bill 172 allowing court
appointed Guardians to receive temporary
assistance to needy families TANF
benefits and the chair recognizes an
award is Frequent Flyer points to
Senator Carson to present your bill
thank you very much Mr chairman and good
afternoon and good afternoon to The
Honorable members of the House children
and family law committee for the record
my name is Sharon Carson I represent
Senate District 14 comprising the towns
of Londonderry Hudson and Auburn and I
have for your consideration this
afternoon Senate Bill 172 which seeks to
permit court appointed Guardians to
receive temporary assistance to needy
families
um
Mr chairman I think again we've had a
lot of information today about kids and
and trying to do the right things for
kids and this is another one of those
cornerstones this bill was a a request
of the Department of Health and Human
Services
and what this bill does is it allows
non-related legal Guardians for kids to
qualify for TANF benefits the same way
that related legal Guardians for kids
qualify for TANF benefits
former Division III Vice chair and a
former Senator Aaron Hennessey when she
was in the house had a meeting with
director ribsum in a family last year
the family was an older couple and were
the legal guardians of four or five
children who were not related by blood
but who were for all of their purposes
their grandchildren for many years they
were the children of their daughters
longtime partner
when parents developed serious substance
abuse issues these grandparents obtained
legal guardianship of the kids but the
TANF program only allowed the benefit
for blood relatives so they didn't
qualify and really could not afford to
care for all of those children
after the meeting the Department of
Health and Human Services met with the
federal government
which told DHHS that they could approve
dhh's dhhs's plan to apply TANF benefits
to these types of situation but that our
statute would need to be amended in
order to authorize this this is why you
have the bill in front of you today
there is enough money in TANF to cover
this so it's all federal dollars there
is no general fund impact and the Senate
did pass this unanimously
Mr chairman as I said earlier we've had
a lot of discussion especially today in
this committee about children and
supporting children keeping them out of
our systems this is another way to keep
these kids connected to families that
have raised them even though those
families are not related by blood
we want to preserve that we want to
preserve that safety net for them we
want to preserve what's normal as much
as we can for these kids so instead of
them moving them out of a loving family
situation and being placed with
strangers in foster care Let's help
those families that are trying to do the
right thing by these kids and provide
that environment for them they need some
help
all you need to do is look at what's
happening
um ins in our uh economy today where the
price of of goods is has gone up so much
especially food and the price of the
packaging has gone has gotten smaller so
families are having to spend more and
more of a limited budget on on their
food so they need some help and I see
this bill as a way to help it's going to
help children it's going to help the
families that are taking them in and I
think that's a win-win for everyone so
at this point Mr chairman I will
conclude my testimony and I will try to
answer questions but there are folks
from the Department of Health and Human
Services that would be able to answer I
think your questions a lot better than I
can thank you
thank you Senator thank you very much
I do see one hand yeah representative
Perez I'm working on peripheral vision
thank you thank you Mr shirt and thank
you for um allowing me to speak um I
don't have a question but I just want to
say thank you thank you thank you for
the bottom of my heart thank you for
introducing this bill because this bill
would affect a lot of people uh in my
community especially they
underrepresented communities uh that
affects a lot of the families when
um immigration uh cases happen or when
anything like that happens most of the
time uh relatives or uh someone else
take over the kids and uh thank you
thank you for introducing this bill from
my bottom of my heart I really
appreciate it thank you representative
and thank you Senator thank you very
much Mr chairman we're going for the hat
trick okay you know what that is I'll
leave that up to you okay and your chair
recognizes representative David
rochewitz from Littleton
thank you Mr chairman uh members of the
committee for the record my name is
David roseford I'm from Littleton I
represent Grafton one I'm here to to
voice my support here for Senate Bill
172 and just just relay uh some personal
experience that we've had in our family
um
in 2019 uh a friend of my daughters my
oldest daughters was going through a
tough time in her home and it got to a
point where her mom here in Littleton
was not able to take care of her her
anymore and she was placed with her
biological father in Maine and that
lasted for not very long a couple of
months and it was clear to everyone
around that that situation in Maine was
not ideal for her she was not thriving
she was a senior in high school actually
junior in high school at that time she
was struggling with with new new school
new friends new home new scenarios and
the the situation uh was just was just
not ideal so you know when when when
doors open for you you you tend to look
at them and try to try to recognize him
and walk through them so it came to a
point where she needed to be home in
Littleton but the situation nation that
she would have gone into was not ideal
and she probably would not have been
permitted to be in that situation so at
the time my wife and I uh we went
through the court system and got a
guardianship of this young woman and we
knew it was going to be for a temporary
time
but it was going to be able to provide
her with some stability where she could
continue to be with her friends in her
school in her community that she had
known uh from from from the get-go so it
was then that our family really started
getting a taste for what that what that
meant what the guardianship was and we
realized that there are things that are
covered we were able to get our Medicaid
benefits and were able to make sure that
she could continue to see her her
primary care physician while she lived
with us but the little things the little
things that make a big difference in
these kids lives uh going to the prom
going to get your hair done she was
seeing Physicians for various things and
some of the things are not covered uh
would would have been covered now for us
it was it was one child that was for a
very short period of time but this would
really speak to the folks and help the
people that you're going to hear from in
a little bit that have responded to the
things in our society that uh are big
issues we debate these issues in
Representatives Hall all the time but
it's the people that are rolling up
their sleeves and getting their hands
dirty in the communities this bill is
going to help so I just came to um voice
my support for this urge you to to
support this if you look at the fiscal
note and the funding it's it's not
something that's going to be burdensome
to us but it will pay off in dividends
to our communities into those the parts
of the communities that are really
suffering
in the the situations that our society
is facing so thank you and uh
hopefully we can get hopefully we can
get that hat trick thank you
representative Rochford thank you
chair recognizes Karen Hebert from DHHS
here
good afternoon my name is Karen Hebert I
am the director for the division of
economic stability for the Department of
Health and Human Services
so thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee and thank you for
uh any questions you may have about the
TANF program and general be able to
answer but the department does support
this bill we do recognize the need to be
able to support this population of
people find Family Dynamics in the
country really are changing so we want
our environment to be able to change
with that and there is a tremendous need
we hear story after story about
individuals who are taking care of
children who they're not related to so
we wanted to act on this and take steps
in order to be able to help those
particular individuals to help these
kids so more individuals are end up
taking maybe it's a friend or neighbor
of somebody who has a child that has
this kind of need we're hearing more of
an increase of these situations so the
department really would like to be able
to respond and support these families
the other aspect of that is preventative
from uh being a part of the child
welfare system or becoming part of the
child welfare system which attorney
margeson could certainly speak to better
than I can but there is a preventative
Factor here that I think is really
important to make a note of so if you
have any questions I'm happy to answer
any questions for Miss Hebert
representative long
thank you Mr chairman um so I noticed in
here there's no income qualifiers is
that the case in tan if this is not
going to be sold I take in a grandchild
I'm doing okay
there's no income qualifies I could
still qualify for what this bill will
apply for correct that's my
understanding yes that's great thank you
representative Bickford
thank you Mr chairman I'm on the same
line here I think
my concern is
um
once you've had this guidingship granted
to you
and you would like to get some money to
help to fray costs would you not first
have to look into child support from the
natural parents
that is absolutely an option and
actually a requirement of the TANF
program that if you are a recipient of
TANF you're required to cooperate with
the Bureau of Child Support Services in
order for them to pursue child support
against the parents of that child so yes
that there are exceptions to that
but generally speaking yes they would
need to then cooperate with the
Department to pursue child support if
they aren't already okay thank you
we were told that the funding is federal
is that in perpetuity or is this like a
three-year Grant and then we need to
pick it up no this is permanent as much
as we can count on Washington's
permanency yes sir thank you any other
questions
yes representative Raymond
uh thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so currently TANF is
capped at how many years like an
individual or family can have Tana for
themselves is there a limit for years
for this program so if someone were to
for example take custody or guardianship
of a of a young child would they have
support throughout the child's lifetime
thank you for the question and I'm going
to defer to our subject matter expert
Miss McKinley to help answer that
question from the Department
thanks
so as far as time frames for this
program specifically there is not a time
frame so if it's regular TANF it's a
five-year limit but for the program that
they would fall under it would be no
limit
or until the child turns 18.
any further questions for Ms Hebert
seeing none the chair next calls on you
know what I'm gonna do
Colleen McKinley yeah my timing was just
off I actually just put my name on there
just to be available for any questions
when it comes to the TANF program and
what we're offering for this bill
any representative McMahon
thank you Mr chairman uh Ms McKinley
just the clarification on the statement
you just made a relative to 18 being the
TANF
funding limit
if it's a handicapped individual would
that go to go to 21
so it actually goes up to the age of 20
if an individual is still in high school
it doesn't go based upon disability
but now we know it's if you're in high
school to age 20. yep full-time all
right thank you very much
representative long
uh thank you Mr chairman just just to
Define more to me the um
you know that this goes on for the life
you know for the until the child turns
18 or or what have you uh and it's
defined uh it's segregated by allowing
court appointed Guardians so it's court
appointed Guardians
um that could receive this TANF benefit
uh for as long as as long as they need
it is that is that the case correct okay
great thank you
since I got for Christmas a book of all
the laws that have to do with anyway I
just read it and I see that the only
change to 167 6 V is putting in or a
court appointed Guardian so everything
else has been humming along real happy
since whenever and this is the only
change right correct good
foreign
any other questions seeing none thank
you but don't go far okay
okay all right you may sit down
chair recognizes David Miller
Mr Miller come on up
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh my name is David Miller uh
I am a quarter point of the uh Guardian
uh four and a half years ago we took in
three children that were the uh niece
and nephews of one of our biological
Sons girlfriends
and uh
we had never met them before the parents
have
ongoing uh drug problems and the fact uh
just last week we had a herring to
terminate their parental rights
where we're not related we don't qualify
for any of the uh any of the benefits
and having uh three children they're
currently 8 13 and
16. as I said four and a half years
we've had them and the grocery bill went
up substantially
uh the uh price of oil gasoline
um they're all three in
um in sports so both in high school and
AAU Sports so there's a lot of traveling
involved uh with them all year long and
some nights uh during basketball season
we're going three directions at once so
uh
we uh
just looking for a little help we don't
want we don't want someone else to raise
them for us because I think we're doing
a pretty good job of that ourselves but
uh a little bit of help would go a long
way for us
thank you sir for what you're doing
a question representative Grossman
not a question a statement what am I
supposed to do I know I'm not but it's
in German and I won't know yes I will go
ahead thank you so much
um
I think you've come before our committee
before you look familiar and um I just
want to thank you for being just amazing
citizens in New Hampshire
I appreciate that
um the children have enriched Our Lives
as much as we've enriched there as I'm
sure so
representative Greg I'll do my best to
make it a question but um would you
believe we don't hear great cases like
this very often and you are so
appreciated and um you know we're all
here for the better betterment of these
kids and thank goodness for you we
really appreciate you thank you
appreciate it thank you
we're moving on and the other questions
for Miss Miller
thank you sir and thank you for the work
you're doing
chair recognizes Liz scrutin from the
New Hampshire children's Trust
good morning good morning oh my goodness
good afternoon chairman and committee
members
um as chairman said I am Liz scrutin and
I'm a program director at New Hampshire
children's trust
um I'm here today to voice our strong
support for Senate Bill 172 and to share
insights gathered uh over the three and
a half years uh that we have been
launching the Statewide kinship
navigation program rooted within the
network of New Hampshire's Family
Resource Centers the kinship navigation
program provides an array of supports to
kinship families regardless of child
welfare involvement
it doesn't matter what their
relationship is the legal status of
those families the program is free it's
voluntary and it aims to strengthen and
sustain the well-being of Kinship
Caregivers and the children in their
care
um this overall helps with reducing
system barriers economic stressors and
it increases the protective factors
which they alluded to earlier when they
send those prevention strategies so the
decrease to placement disruptions for
children and kinship care our frcs
around the state have offered such
support to 755 families in 821 children
that have been placed in their care over
the course of the program
we know that a child's need for
uninterrupted sense of love and
belonging is necessity for healthy
development and that a growing body of
Research indicates placement with kin
can be the next best option a child has
to safely remain in care of his or her
biological parents many children however
have bonds with individuals who are not
related by birth or adoption or marriage
just as the case in the Millers
and they have those really strong
relationships with them as well these
fictive can can provide care and
stability for a child when out of home
placement is absolutely necessary
in 70 percent of kinship placements the
driving factor is substance use disorder
in one or both of those parents
these can or fictive Kinship Caregivers
agree to take the child or children who
cannot or should not remain at least in
the short term in the care with their
parents in many cases dcaf also makes
the determination that the placement
with these kin or fictive kin families
is in the best interest of the children
or child so these placements are court
ordered we know that despite the
prevalence that these care Arrangements
both inside and outside of the Foster
system have there are many contacts
contexts in which the law does not
recognize them in these relationships
in the best interest of the children
these Kinship Caregivers should have the
same access to TANF as the biological
parents and this bill takes a really
important step in acknowledging and
supporting both kinship and fictive
caregivers
um the effort to expand TANF eligibility
to court appointed a court appointed
Guardians including the effective can
demonstrates New Hampshire's commitment
to the health and well-being of our most
vulnerable children and we do urge the
passage of this important measure thank
you so much for having us
will you take questions I can try and I
have my subject experts behind me if I
need them
representative disamoni
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I hope this is an
easy one for you
how many effective in kinship care
families do we currently have sure so
this is out of a percentage uh taken
within the last three years span it's
about six and a half percent so you
don't have a whole number for you but of
100 of those families served in an FRC
capacity so these are just at the Family
Resource Centers six and a half percent
are fictive kin families
follow up please follow up thank you I
too want to express my
um pleasure at being able to hopefully
assist families that do this uh this
goes above and beyond it takes a village
to raise a child these people are really
putting themselves out there and I thank
you from the bottom of my heart
I'm going to ask a would you believe
question would you believe the fount of
all wisdom here Dr Google
says that not recognizing fictive can
relationships
harms children 100 so this one gets a
vote
thank you thank you
that's a great word fictive
chair recognizes Patty Stolt is it Stolt
or stolty
stulte yes
good afternoon from FRC I'm going to go
out on a limb and say that's family
Council no no sorry Federalists don't
like writing Rehabilitation committee
what is it it is the Family Resource
Center at Gorham got it
name is Patty stolti and thank you for
listening to me I am here because I am
the executive director of The Family
Resource Center in Gorham that covers
Northern New Hampshire
and I am also a parent of two children
that are non-related to me that I've
raised
um one since she was two and the other
since he was five and they are adults
thriving in our local communities and
I'm very very proud and I'd like to
reiterate what
um Mr Miller said which is they have
given me far more than I have given them
and there have been times when I've
really struggled financially so I
understand that but when people are
willing to step up
um and more and more substance misuse is
really seeping into our communities and
causing Havoc I don't need to tell you
that and quite simply I just want to say
these families that are willing to step
up really do need the support and and I
and again you know I never want to put a
burden on our state
um that isn't going to be really
productive and this is a very productive
investment in our families and in these
and our children because our children
deserve they deserve this it's it's I I
want to say it's a no-brainer but that's
how I feel I just we see it time and
time again and we see the outcomes we
know the Millers are very well their
children are just amazed
at what love these two people give them
and and it's a really beautiful thing so
I from the heart side I just want to say
please give this I urge you to consider
the the importance of this bill
any questions any questions
the weather up north is is very nice
Littleton
I grew up thinking that was west of
Boston on route two okay
and the chair now recognizes Tina Miller
from Littleton which is up north if that
is North actually yeah thank you like I
said I'm Tina Miller I'm from Littleton
and we are court appointed Guardians for
three of the kids that we took four and
a half years ago and you know at that
point in time in our life we were empty
nesters
we were getting ready to travel the
world the only way we travel now is
with basketballs and soccer cleats and
smelly smelly shoes you know it's but we
wouldn't change it these kids have
you know they've done a lot for us
and they thank us every day every time
every meal that we feed them every
single one of them thank you for the
food thank you we're out to dinner and
they'll say thank you for giving us food
and it's like
what they grew up on was Cumby's Pizza
when when we were going out to dinner
one night they were very upset that they
weren't having Cumby's pizza because
that was the drugstop that they used to
make
they didn't know any different
and
you know the oldest the oldest boy just
got his braces off a month ago what did
he do last a couple weekends ago through
his retainers in the trash at the mall
I'm like really so there was 750 on last
Friday we had to dish out
and now we've got AAU this week that's
twelve hundred dollars that we have to
somehow find for him because he's he's
good he's a good basketball player and
this is what he wants to do with his
life he wants to play basketball we're
looking at colleges you know he he
deserves a chance at life too
and basketball sneakers are expensive
you're looking at two three hundred
dollars a pop
for good basketball sneakers and he goes
through at least two pairs a year and
then his sister's coming up who I just
had to order cleats the other not last
night no it was last night you know
because
softball started and now we need bats
and I told her we're not getting a bat
you know and then the little guy pops up
well I need a bat too and I said but he
says my cleats were cheaper because we
went to the consignment store for ten
dollars and bought ours I'm like you're
right you know it's just the little
things if we could get a little bit of
help groceries 350 a week easily and
that's that's on a that's on a low week
you know we both work two jobs so that
we can afford these kids we didn't have
to work two jobs I I had a home daycare
for 22 years
but we ran out of room in the house I
had to give that up
and go out to work and he's working two
jobs I work two jobs
a little bit of help when we had the
pandemic card the EBT card that was so
helpful we didn't have to worry you know
we've got enough money for extra food
you know it's the little things and
we're not asking for a million dollars
it's a little bit of help with clothes
or food
thank you so much and on one condition
you tell your oldest son that when he
signs his pro basketball career you get
a tenth of that contract that's right he
knows that
he had his first little fan this year
that we had to sign an autographed
picture for
yep so thank you so much for testifying
and
Beth margison from dcyf did I get it
right this time Beth I got that right
and Marge just said I got it right
finally it takes me a while with names
to get them right well also as
representative Petrino pointed out I
don't really write very clearly on my
pink card you nailed this one I did
because he told me to do that on the
elevator on the way up and also I was
admiring representative panic's gorgeous
handwriting and so inspired by her I
tried very hard to make sure that I
wrote very clearly
um so anyway a little hard to to follow
the Millers but I will try
um Beth margeson dcyf general counsel
legislative liaison uh thank you Mr
chair Vice chair and all the members of
the committee dcyf obviously supports
this bill very strongly it is part of
our initiative to keep children with
people they know
in their communities and out of our
system and providing financial support
to those who are loving enough
to take them on is something that we
wholeheartedly support and I'll take any
questions if if you have them how do you
follow the Miller's tale right yeah I'm
just hoping I can get off quickly
representative long
thank you Mr chairman I yeah I just want
to be clear on
um because it's I don't see it in here
that it's code it's any court appointed
Guardian so whether you're a relative or
not you qualify yes that is correct you
do not have to be a relative to become a
guardian okay
and also the length of TANF
this is for the Youth of the child
um I will defer to TANF because I'm not
a tenant uh expert but they set up until
the child is 18. all right and and how
is that defined
how was that the finding here
I
yeah how do we how do we know that this
is not the regular five-year TANF the
existing statute
there's different
um why don't you come
okay pull a chair up please
all right we can we can work this
so there are different rules when it
comes to TANF and where they fall sorry
there are different rules when it comes
to tanup and where they fall in the
program that they fall in so um the
program that they would fall in when it
comes to the bill that you're looking at
is redefining specified relative so a
relative when they apply for TANF is
eligible for what's called Fab cash
which is Tana but it is a program that
is for individuals who are relatives who
are caring for another relative so not a
parent so those five-year laws and rules
are for a different kind of TANF so the
bill that you're looking at is the
specified relative piece of the
caretaker relative part which is falls
under tanith under the fat program so
that's why when you're looking at the
bill it's very specific to relatives who
receive TANF and not parents who
received Tana right okay that defines it
thank you
any other questions for the assembled
panel representative McMahon
yes Ms marches and then also the
Madame attorney next to you there
um just to clarify does this require uh
you know reading the bill and the
implied that there'll be no problem with
this but does it require a CMS appeal
we'll have to defer to you on that
no okay and just to follow up follow up
and just going back to my years of doing
this through Health and Human Services
was since there's an additional spending
component
it does not require that adjustment of
this the split between federal and state
to have an appeal process that could get
in the way of this being effectuated
immediately I mean within the context of
timing
so can you just say that sorry say can
you say it one more time just what you
just said I'll put it in different ways
who's got the money
so it's not a new program it's part of
the the the the program that already
exists and so for that group again for
relatives who care for their
grandchildren or their their nephew or
niece that funding is 100 federally
funded so that's why all we're doing is
changing the terminology of who is
allowed to be a specified relative which
now includes a court appointed Guardian
so that's why the funding we're not
asking for a different kind of funding
source or
um changing TANF per se as adding a
different program we're just redefining
who we are saying are caretaker
relatives
just going from the fiscal know where
where it's referring to 2.1 million uh
that money and and I'm I'm obviously for
this it's going back when dealing with
disability issues and the funding and
In-Home Care
that a bureaucratic a faceless
bureaucrat from Washington will not get
in the way of this moving forward so
your guidance is in that regard no cons
no concern in that
you do not believe so or if you actually
stand behind your words
oh
I can parse though
yeah I'm hoping to avoid an appeal we
can get a bench
thank you for your question I I believe
that what you're referring to may be
with respect to the tan of
reauthorization by Congress and uh
there's no information available that
would indicate that there would not be
reauthorized but I think that we're all
subjected to the entiretana program
would be subjected to that
right and they'll just close with one
more Mr chairman bring it home thank you
for your continued support indeed sir
the uh knowing what the Millers have
just spoke of and I would not want want
them to be disappointed and then the
expectation of helping with their
funding is there anything further you
would recommend that we could do as
legislators
in whatever way you would uh seem
appropriate to ensure that this does
happen and it might happen that if it's
going to happen when is this fully in
blacklet of law that the money comes to
New Hampshire sure so it's in the budget
um and within the budget as well we have
asked for an increase to the maintenance
of effort for that particular budget so
in order to receive 32 million dollars
in federal funding to support the TANF
program we actually 38 million excuse me
we have to come up with 32 million in
maintenance of effort which is General
funds and expend that so because of
concerns in the budget in order to meet
that requirement we have asked for right
now in hb2 it it reads two and a half
million dollars to include in the
maintenance of effort to ensure that we
do receive these federal funds so I
think I would just ask that uh for that
kind of support when the budget goes
through its process
okay thank you very much
any other questions for the
distinguished panel
thank you distinguished panel
thank you very much
and with that I closed the hearing on
Senate Bill
172 and in consultation with my vice
chair ranking member
I would like to ask
you think we ought to go forward with
this about right now and give the Senate
to the hat-trick I agree okay open the
exact session on Senate Bill 172 just a
reminder that
um whoever makes the motion writes the
blurb and I will expect you to use the
word fictive at least once in your
report so with that in mind who would
like to move this bill
you've just made that very unattractive
but I'll do it
you can reference The Miller's tale if
you wish it's from Chaucer but that's
that's bonus points so I'll move uh
ought to pass on this bill
OTP
by representative Raymond and who would
like to Second it who hasn't
representative Seidel from the either
the other side of the playground or the
other playground depending on who you
speak to is second so everybody
in the room it looks at
the motion before us is ought to pass
moved by representative Raymond and
seconded by representative Seidel
allowing court appointed Guardians to
receive temporary assistance to needy
families benefits that is the motion
before us and when the clerk is ready
please call the roll
chairman Pearson
Vice chairman long yes
representative DeSimone yes
representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
Seidel yes representative Grossman
yes representative Levesque is not in
representative Petrino yes
representative Perez yes representative
Greg yes representative Moulton is not
in representative Raymond yes
that would be 14 years and two absents
fourteen fourteen to zero the bill
passes any
uh objection to consent calendar of
course not we all voted for it what's
that
it has a fiscal note but is that New
Hampshire money in the fiscal note or
fed
I'm going to go for consent they can
always say no I'm not going to say no
for them
okay but good point good good
observation and this ends
the exact session on Senate Bill 172 and
I think we have one more report I have
seen mine obviously representative
panics there's one more due from
Grossmont yeah
so we have a just a little bit less than
45 minutes before the Judiciary
Committee joins us and a bunch of judges
and for our continuing education session
learn the word fictive committee it's a
good word
oh
you know we couldn't get the millions
virtual Olympics
a little bit more time
thank you
I'd like to call to order this
continuing education event for the
children and family law committee and
the Judiciary Committee
we found that some of the bills that
have come before us having to do with
the law or the Judiciary Committee we're
not ready for prime time sometimes there
were misuses of legal terms sometimes
the rules of Criminal Court were soon to
be the same as the rules for civil court
and so on and I got to thinking if we
had a continuing education event and
brought senior senior Judiciary people
to us they could make a presentation to
us and we would learn some more things
about the law so next time our bills
would have a greater chance of being
heard and not either killed or retained
here's the format for how we're going to
be working today
the Judiciary folks will introduce
themselves and make a presentation
if along the way you have a question
you will go over to the table where the
committee researcher is
waving
cards at you and her hand too
and you will fill out the question on
the card we will not take questions from
the audience in a direct verbal way
you'll fill the cards out and there's a
box where you'll put them in
somewhere along the line
Judiciary Committee chairman Bob Lynn
will pick up a pile of those cards and
sort them by type because many of the
questions will be similar to other
questions so we'll group them or he'll
group them so that we can ask one
composite question
it's not proper to raise a question
about a particular court case
first of all because that is considered
unethical in a case like we're in today
secondly the justices may not be
familiar with it and thirdly we're not
looking at particular cases we're
looking at process what is the process
is it being followed should there be a
different process what is the procedure
those are the kinds of broad questions
that can be put to the justices
now in a meeting with chairman Lynn and
the justices I came to the belief that
they are coming both to explain but also
to listen
and there will be some things where I
know I'll learn a lot I made assumptions
that were incorrect
but they're also going to hear some of
the many concerns that people have
raised and until he proved to me
otherwise I think they're going to do
something about it and as I told them
those are the nice carrots the stick I
have in my back pocket is several
retained bills that are really
trying to straighten out Judiciary so
I've got that stick I don't think I'll
need it
but I got it so now that I've pretty
well alienated everybody in the room
I will call upon the Chief Justice sir
if you would introduce yourself and your
colleagues
good morning Mr chairman Mr chairman and
members of both committees thank you
very much for the opportunity to be here
with me today is the administrator of
the Circuit Court David King Judge David
King and to my right is Judge Michael
Garner who is a Circuit Judge sitting in
Laconia New Hampshire and it previously
served as a mayoral master
if I just can dive in Mr chairman please
do sir um and you're quite correct we we
had the honor of meeting with both of
the chairs and um we we wanted this
opportunity to come and brief you on
um some Basics about the Judiciary also
give you uh a briefing on what something
called the weighted caseload study which
is a evidence-based analysis of the
resources that our Judiciary needs in
New Hampshire
and then judge king is prepared to give
the Committees some statistics relating
to the Family Division and judge Gardner
who uh is very well versed in this area
of the law and the procedures prepared
to help the committee and members of the
public with questions relating to that
so we are very grateful for the
opportunity I do want to reiterate what
the chair said we want to hear comments
we want to hear feedback as public
officials that's our duty and if we can
do better we want to do better
and it is in that spirit that we are
here
uh I do have slides and I've distributed
I think every member of the committee's
has them uh so I've covered slide two uh
Chief uh would it be possible if we have
some left over we keep a few for
committee members who aren't here but
those particularly in the audience who
are house members and Bill writers might
have access and
maybe the way they're distributed people
could look on with one another
thank you sir okay slide number three is
our mission and it is something that we
take very very seriously and we try to
live by every day and that goes through
before not just the judges but our 800
employees in the judicial branch
the next slide just gives you a visual
overview of the judicial branch we are
comprised of two trial courts the
circuit court and the Superior Court one
Appellate Court the Supreme Court and
one office that provides administrative
support for the Judiciary it's called
the administrative office of the courts
and I'm going to detail or judge king
and I will detail each one of these
courts just to level set everyone and I
recognize in advance that for many of
you this is uh you're well versed in
this but I want to just make sure we're
we're all on the same page
uh circuit court judge king
thank you Chief so I'm on slide six and
uh by way a review for some of you and
maybe new for others the Circuit Court
was created uh with an effective date of
July 1st 2011 by this body it's a
legislatively created court and at the
time we were under some fairly we the
state of New Hampshire running some
fairly tight budget times and we were
asked to get creative and see if there
are ways that we could create
efficiencies for the state in the court
system and what we did at the time was
we took three limited jurisdiction
courts we took the district court the
Probate Court where I came from and the
Family Division and we collapsed them
into one court and we called it the
Circuit Court we just kind of pulled
that name out of the air I said we
called it the circuit court because
Supreme Court was already taken so we
needed to come up with something so we
called it the circuit court and the bill
was introduced in January of 2011 and I
think Governor Lynch signed it in
mid-may it was one of the biggest
changes in the court system since the
consolidation in 1983 which was House
Bill 200 back then I was a member of
House Judiciary in the 8384 session
which I was shocked to do the math today
was 40 years ago but we when we created
the Circuit Court it was House Bill 609
and we had asked the legislature for 10
years to implement it so that we could
do the restructuring by attrition and we
were told that we had to implement it by
July 1st so we did we went from 115
clerks and deputies across those three
courts down to 52
clerks and deputies we brought all those
folks into a room and we said we're
going to post 52 jobs you're all free to
apply but basically half of you are
going to lose your jobs and it was
probably one of the most difficult
things I've done in court administration
and so and at the time we had 45
full-time judicial officers on the bench
across those three courts which included
13 marital Masters and today there's
only one of those left and it's me the
rest are the other 44 judges and Masters
have retired summer some Masters are now
judges like judge Garner some part-time
judges have become full-time judges but
of those 45 judicial officers 44 are no
longer on the bench
slide seven uh it was no mystery to the
creation of this we created 10 circuits
and each County was a circuit and we
wanted to try to change as little as
possible uh to try to get this through
the legislature as seamlessly as we
could so we have 34 Circuit Court
locations around the state they're all
depicted on this map we have 10 probate
divisions those were the where the
probate courts were originally
established in the county seats and now
we have a district Division and a Family
Division and all of the other 31
locations since we created the Circuit
Court we've closed plasta which was a
really small Court down in the lower
part of the part of the state
slide 8 gives you what we're using as a
an annual circuit court case volume and
because of the covid-19 pandemic and a
pretty significant reduction in
many different case types we have used
the average of fiscal years 17 18 and 19
but using those years the circuit court
case volume is over 126 000 cases a year
in addition to that we have a number of
cases that are reopened and just in the
divorce parenting world that's another 3
700 to 5400 cases a year that get added
to our dockets
on the next slide uh what we show the
number of Circuit Court judges and the
chief will explain the weighted caseload
study but currently as of today we have
41 full-time judges on the bench we have
one full-time vacancy and we actually
have five part-time judges because judge
Maloney just turned 70 and she's now a
referee in addition to that we have
four senior active judges that we use
from time to time who can work part-time
those are Judges who have retired but
are still under the age of 70. we have
one marital master who is retired who
still
sits occasionally and we have 12
retired judges who are over the age of
70 that we still need in order to try to
meet the caseload that we have because
we just don't have enough judges so 12
judges over age 70 who are regularly
hearing cases as senior referees and
everything that that they do has to be
co-signed by a judge so it's not a real
efficient use but we schedule in the
Circuit Court by judge days
so if you take those 126 000 cases using
the weighted caseload that translates to
16 352 judge days that we need to move
the volume of cases that we have
for this year calendar year 2023 when we
put the judicial schedule together
we were able to Cobble together ten
thousand five hundred and eighteen days
so that's all of the full-time judges
that's the part-time judges we have five
part-time judges they sit anywhere from
a handful of days up to a couple hundred
days they tell us how many they are
willing to do when we try to add a few
more to that
and then we take the senior active
judges and the referees War over 70 and
that all of those all in added up to ten
thousand five hundred and eighteen days
so you can see we're we're thousands of
days short of scheduling what we need to
be able to move those cases
our other trial court is the superior
court if you go to page 11 it's a brief
description of the jurisdiction of the
Superior Court it is our court of
General jurisdiction it is the only
Court in our state which has conducts
jury trials
uh it it has uh jurisdiction over all
felony crimes and all civil matters over
twenty five thousand dollars so a very
wide
uh range of jurisdiction on the next
slide you will see what
I'm sure is very familiar we have 11
Superior Court locations in New
Hampshire
one in each County two in Hillsboro in
Manchester in Nashua
on slide 13 you will see the analog to
what you saw in slide 8 with the Circuit
Court
about 18 000 cases in superior court
over the same period of time that judge
king described and you can see the
breakdown in the um in the in the
graphic the largest cohort of cases are
criminal cases
the next slide you will see our head
count in Superior Court it has remained
unchanged uh since at least 2011 we have
21 authorized judges and one chief
justice currently we were fully
accounted for in terms of judges no
vacancies at the moment
so those are our true trial courts we
have one Appellate Court in New
Hampshire that is the Supreme Court
Supreme Court sits here in Concord and
on page 16
you will see the justices of the Supreme
Court there are four associate justices
and one chief justice
in addition to our duties and as
appellate judges we serve as leaders of
the judicial branch and the Chief
Justice in particular has administrative
responsibilities for the judicial branch
our duties include
overseeing issues such as attorney
discipline attorney emissions liaison
with the New Hampshire Bar Association
and development of court rules
on the next slide slide 17 you will see
our breakdown of cases it's about
625 650 cases a year of that about
150 125 to 150 at uh receive full-blown
oral arguments and and decisions that
are reported in the New Hampshire
reports I just came from a day of oral
argument to be over here we hold them
about four times four to six times a
month
the rest of our cases are all
handled their five sets of eyes on every
single case that runs through our court
they're just disposed of in various
different ways including by orders and
so on
on the next slide uh we are supported by
the administrative office of the courts
about 55 people who work there their
location is over at one Granite place
and they they provide support in terms
of Information Technology Human
Resources legal government relations
that are back office support
and it's a fairly complex organization
as you've seen in our slides we have
over 40 locations around New Hampshire
and about 800 employees
so let's begin uh the discussion of
what what is called the weighted
caseload study and if you turn to page
or slide 20
um
of two legislatures ago judge king can
correct me uh this legislature
authorized uh appropriated funds for us
to undertake a weighted caseload study a
weighted caseload study is an
evidence-based analysis of how many
resources we need in terms of judges and
case processing staff given our case
load
in a way to caseload study is in
contrast to other ways that that policy
makers may decide how to assign judicial
resources
but we feel this is the best most
reliable
evidence-based
means to do it and our feeling is backed
up by legislation which was enacted in
which by which this legislature endorsed
away the caseload study one was
conducted in 2005 and then
one was conducted last year in 2022.
um slide 21 talks about other methods
that may be employed to determine how
many judges and Court staff we need
population-based formulas for formal is
based purely on the number of cases but
again
um in 490f Colon 11 this legislature has
endorsed a weighted caseload study
on slide 22 I
the basic methodology the basic approach
is to take the number of cases determine
a case weight and then determine how
many resources measured in core
personnel and judges are needed to make
our workload
on slide 23
this is the history of our weighted
caseload study in New Hampshire as I
mentioned one was conducted in 2005 at
the time the trial courts had 482
positions
in 2022 when we conducted this study
there were 514 positions
do this study we on next slide
slide 24 we retained the services of the
national Center for state courts the
national Center for state courts is an
extraordinary resource which serves all
State and territorial courts in our
country
and they have substantial experience and
expertise since in assisting
jurisdictions in doing way to caseload
studies both poor judges and staff so we
retained them to assist us with the
study
on the next slide slide 25
you will see a basic methodology or
calculation for how a weighted caseload
is determined for one of our case types
small claims are heard in the Circuit
Court
and you can see that if you look at the
the chart on the right hand side of
slide 25
during our survey period which was six
weeks at the beginning of last year
judges uh
recorded in court processing staff
recorded 22 324 minutes
to um
that they worked on small claims
cases there were 29 days of collection
during this period you divide those two
numbers and then multiply it by the
number of judicial working days and you
have the Statewide annualized minutes
for small claims cases
then you divide that
by the number of court filings for small
claims and you see that the case weight
for this case type is 12.38 minutes
which means on average a judge spends
12.38 minutes on a small claims case
now is my colleagues will explain that's
an average I mean it's some or less some
or more small claims cases can if
they're if they're settled no no time is
needed or recorded but that's the
average and it this this slide is simply
to demonstrate how we come up with a
weighted case
number
um
is a
we needed data for each one of our case
types and our staff and judges recorded
the data as I said for 29 days at the
beginning of last year
and it was those that time that was the
essential data point that helped us
build our conclusions
and led to our conclusions on page slide
27 you will see our Baseline staff for
the way to caseload study at the time it
was conducted
broken down by judicial officers in
various categories of staff
on the circuit court side you will see
that there are 44.32
judicial officers included in the study
at the time I just want you to footnote
that because we'll come back to it and
explain
explain that
number a little bit more in the context
of our conclusions
on the next slide you will see that we
had extraordinary participation and
therefore highly reliable data we had a
hundred percent participation by our
judges and our staff
over 29 days so in addition to doing
performing their day-to-day function
functions and serving the people of our
state in our court system they were
recording the time on each one of the
case types they were working on
on slide 29 we summarize the results
um
the national Center found that we needed
563.77 judicial officers and staff to
process cases
in both of our trial courts and that's
about 50 more positions than in our
current budget
and of those broken down the Circuit
Court needs were identified as an
additional 37 positions in Superior
Court an additional 12 positions both
judges and staff
I want to if we could just go out of
order skip to slide 31.
in addition the study
tried to capture a very important data
source which is the reality in both of
our trial courts is that clerks Deputy
clerks and other managers are actually
doing the work of our court Assistance
or core process our case processing
staff
and you can see that across both trial
courts that
work that's impounded in our clerks and
our Deputy clerks that should be with
court processing staff amounts to
57.3 positions in both of our trial
courts broken down by about 40 in the
Circuit Court in 17 and a half in the
Superior Court
so in addition to the numbers that we
saw on page 29 these are also the
reality of what we're dealing with we
have clerks and Deputy clerks who are
who are doing case processing work and
that's a key data point that we're able
to capture
on page 30
um
this summarizes
the basic conclusions of the national
centers work for us which in the Circuit
Court in terms of judges
um
we
require
21.35 additional judges
but I want you to footnote that we'll
come back to it and you can see the
breakdown among staff in Superior Court
three and a half new judges
and for the most part additional staff
is needed
it's broken down on page 30.
so page 32 I'm going to ask judge king
to explain this
page 32 level sets the the number of
judges
that the national Center identified with
the reality of judicial resources
available to us because the national
Center did not capture the work of some
of our per diem or of our per diem
judges and this chart explains
explains that
so this page actually shows what we had
available to us at the during that six
week period of data collection on the
ground in the circuit court so we had at
that time 40 full-time judges we still
had one marital Master we had a
full-time child support referee which
was counted as a judge a part-time child
support referee
and then we have we had two we now have
one holdover salaried district court
judges so these were judges that were
appointed before the Circuit Court was
created were appointed to a specific
court for example the Portsmouth
District Court they are still considered
a salary judge and they received the
salary by Statute for that Court to
which they were appointed until they
retire or they turned 70. that's just
unless they become a full-time judge so
it's a little bit of a one-off for us we
have to take the weighted caseload for
that court and then do the math and
that's how their salaries are calculated
um
and then there were adjustments made to
that for
um
there were two authorized full-time
judges in addition to that one marital
Master had retired and one of the two
salary judges had retired and we added a
full-time probate referee just about
exactly when we were doing the study
which was authorized by the legislature
to be able to process our electronically
filed Estates thereby kind of freeing up
a judge from doing that work
and if you get to the bottom line that
the total total shortfall is 17.32
so one on slide 30 the national Center
had identified
21.35 additional judges once you true it
up the real number as as judge king just
explained that the number is
17.32 additional judges needed that is
the bottom line of the study in the
Circuit Court three and a half judges in
the Superior Court
now I'm going to ask both of my
colleagues if they want to explain what
the consequences of not having adequate
inadequate number of judges in court
processing staff are in terms of the
reality of their the caseload in circuit
court and basically how cases are
triaged
yeah so I'll take a stab at that Chief
as I said earlier in my comments the
weighted caseload
calls for 16 352
judge days for 2023 to move the number
of cases and we we can break that down
by case type but there are a lot of
cases that this legislature has told us
have to be resolved in certain time
frames so our landlord tenant cases our
abuse neglect cases our juvenile
delinquency cases some guardianship
cases civil protection orders uh chins
termination of parental rights that's a
big chunk of what we do and even during
the covid-19 pandemic we were required
by Statute to get those cases resolved
in the time frames that you set for us
and we were able to do that we didn't
miss a deadline we had some exceptions
for landlord tenant by Court rule
um but there are a number of cases that
there just are not enough judges on the
bench to get to and those are the cases
that you're hearing from your
constituents that aren't moving as
quickly as they should and we do not
dispute that they are absolutely right
um there are criminal cases that involve
non-incarcerated defendants that it's
taking longer than we would like to get
scheduled for trial and certainly in the
divorce parenting Arena we're not
getting to those cases nearly as quickly
as we would like those are the kinds of
cases that don't have statutorily
dictated deadlines and so we triage the
cases that we have to reach and there's
got to be some slippage somewhere and
it's primarily in non-incarcerated
defendants small claims in civil cases
and in the divorce parenting cases in
order to meet our deadlines we would
need the judges that the weighted
caseload study says that we need so I
think I'm really proud that our judges
are doing as well as they are doing they
work nights and weekends to try to stay
on top of things but there is definitely
a gap and we are not reaching the time
to disposition in all of our cases in
the fashion that we would like to or
being perfectly upfront about that I've
talked to both chairman about that and
it's not a mystery
judge Garner can probably talk about how
we triage
so I was here a couple of months ago I
think to be introduced to the children
and family law section it's nice of you
to have me back again I'm glad to be
back again
just by way of introduction I'm a
circuit court judge I've been a judge
for about seven years I sit in Laconia
almost all of the time
and I'm as a circuit court judge trained
to do all three of the divisions probate
district and family
as it happens we have more work in the
Family Division than in District and so
my week typically is two or three days
of Family Division maybe one or two days
of District division the occasional
probate division assignment my family
um
days are typically either a full day
contested one hearing case that's been
pending for a while or a list day which
is typically 30-minute hearings back to
back beginning at 8 30 and ending at
four o'clock with the lunch hour if I
can conjure that up somewhere
let me just add to what judge king was
saying in terms of our triaging on the
micro level
we have a divorce and parenting cases
which have an enormous spectrum of
complexity some of those cases are
resolved virtually at the time that
they're filed and it's simply a question
of reviewing the paperwork making sure
the forms are in order and approving it
sending it out
some of those are cases which begin in
difficult ways and go through a series
of hearings that may be prompted by
emergency motions or other features
unique to the case
May ultimately end up with full day or
sometimes multi-day final hearings that
involve multiple Witnesses
there may be a guardian ad litem
involved there may be contested
parenting issues contested Financial
issues alimony support property
distribution all of that may be
supported by exhibits which in my recent
experience tend to be expanding rather
than Contracting
and so those cases those complex divorce
and parenting cases are a little bit
unpredictable we don't know which cases
are going to turn into that when they're
first filed we don't have much control
over that
our triage process though on the micro
level on a daily basis is really
threefold
we have emergency motions that are filed
every day again unpredictably either in
divorce parenting cases when there's an
emergency that prompts one party to come
to court and ask for immediate orders or
in domestic violence petition sorts of
cases
in Laconia we get 350 more or less
domestic violence petitions every year
it's unpredictable for us when those
cases are going to come in although we
inexperienced know that Friday afternoon
and Monday mornings tend to be the times
but every day we're going to get
emergency motions that are filed those
motions are reviewed by a judge every
day
not a single one of those cases comes in
and lacks review by a judge and a
decision by a judge whether to Grant an
emergency protective order or emergency
relief and from time to time because our
protocols allow and require for a
hearing for the party who has been
denied relief when they first come in
occasionally those motions and those
filings result in the need for having a
hearing that day
that's pretty rare but it happens
regularly enough that it's worth
mentioning so that's the overlay to our
daily work otherwise our daily work is
managing the cases that have to be
scheduled according to the statutory
deadlines the judge king mentioned those
cases have to be scheduled they have to
be heard and the orders have to be
entered within the certain statutory
deadlines and behind those come our
cases without statutory deadlines and of
varying levels of complexity so my day
is going to be either one or the other
typically in Family Division it's either
a list a or a full day or more than one
full day of final hearings and in the
middle I'm going to get a Sprinkle of
emergency motions that are filed as the
day goes by and I have to carve out time
to make orders on those cases
so our triage is basically emergency
cases cases that have statutory
deadlines that may be creeping up on us
and the divorce and parenting cases that
don't have statutory deadlines and
that's simply how we manage it day to
day in the Family Division and to a
lesser degree in the district division
thank you judge Garner
even even if our judicial head count
where where it needed to be in terms of
the way to caseload
we would not be adequately serving the
citizens of New Hampshire the people of
New Hampshire if we did not augment our
court staff
and uh I'd like to have judge king talk
about
the pressures that we are facing like
every other employer in our state with
respect to current vacancies and the
effects that that has on our ability to
to
um
for for the judges to do their jobs and
for the people to um
receive receive the services that that
they expect from our judiciary
so needless to say during the pandemic
we averaged about 70 to 75 percent of
our staff showing up on any given day
that was a tremendous pressure now that
we're sort of on the back side of that
our biggest challenge is that we're just
not competitive the judicial branch is
not competitive with starting wages our
starting wage for a quarter system 2
which is an entry level position is
around 15 an hour after union dues I
think it's a it's 14 and change we
currently as of this morning have 39
full-time vacant staff positions most of
which have been posted for an extended
period of time three just in the Concord
circuit court court assistant threes
which are not entry levels those are the
next step up that we we just haven't
even had any applications for people
aren't applying to Workforce at those
wages so today we have 37 full-time
vacant positions and three part-time
vacant positions out of 359 total
positions so even at the positions that
are authorized notwithstanding that the
weighted caseload study reflects that we
need another 30 30 plus we have more
than 10 percent of our seats that are
vacant and absent some relief in the
budget for our wage restructuring
they're going to continue to be vacant
and if we don't have staff to process
the orders and get them out it's one
thing for a judge to hold a hearing sign
the order you may see another two to
three weeks before that order gets out
the door because we don't have staff to
process and I'm sure you've heard from
from constituents that that's the case
and that's our reality and our staff
work really really hard
um
and we offer great benefits but we're
finding that the the Millennials don't
care about health insurance because
they're probably on their parents health
insurance or they're not going to get
sick anyway so they don't need health
insurance they just want to know what am
I going to be paid an hour and we have
literally lost folks who have gone to
Dunkin Donuts and fast food restaurants
because they pay more an hour that's
that's our reality
so finally page slide 34 is a summary of
part of our budget request that is in
reflects what we learn from our
evidence-based way to caseload
as to judges you will see that of the 17
you'll recall
judges that the study identified we've
requested seven in in the superior court
of the three and a half uh judges that
were identified as needed we've
requested one in terms of Court staff 31
new clerical staff in the Circuit Court
in one new clerk in the circuit court
and in the Superior Court 4 News
clerical staff and one new law Clerk
so that is a summary of the way the
caseload study I'm now going to ask uh
judge king to give a breakdown of some
statistics relating to the Family
Division
yeah I'm not sure what the Committees
want to hear so I'm happy to not do
anything I put together a few statistics
that I thought you might find
interesting I've already mentioned the
the volume of cases that and those are
in the slides
I want to make the point that
I've already talked about the turnover
in judges but 25 of our full-time judges
have been appointed since 2018 so more
than half our bench has been on the
bench less than five years so these are
Judges that are still in the process of
learning to be judges some of them have
come to us as prosecutors some have come
from various law practices and they have
to be trained as judge Garner said to
learn the breadth of the jurisdiction in
the circuit court so that they're
fungible and we can move them from
location to location
the judges are often in the courtrooms
kind of on their own in the circuit
court if you go to a superior court
you'll see a court monitor which is the
person who's with the judge responsible
to make sure the record's running
properly and has headphones on to make
sure everything's functional
our judges are often responsible for
turning the recorders on and off which
are not located on the bench they're
somewhere else or the court security
offices turn them on or off we we don't
have court monitors and our judges don't
have law Clerks so in the Superior Court
in the Supreme Court there are a lot of
Clerks who are lawyers who assist with
writing orders doing research our judges
are on their own to do that we have
three staff attorneys to service roughly
60 judicial officers in the circuit
court and so you can expect that they
don't have a lot of time to be sitting
in on hearings and helping to write
orders when the pandemic started and we
moved to more remote hearings our
costs for telephone was going through
the roof and so we immediately began to
track the number of hearings and the
number of remote hearings and I thought
you might find this statistic
interesting since mid-march of 2020 in
the Circuit Court as of the end of
February Circuit Court judges have
conducted 469 532 hearings
of those two hundred and two thousand
four hundred and twenty three had at
least one party who participated
remotely either by telephone or by video
so about 43 percent but almost 470 000
hearings since March of 2020.
most of the folks who come to the
Circuit Court don't have attorneys we
call them self-represented litigants
about 85 percent of parenting divorce
cases have at least one unrepresented
party
that has its own challenges
and of all of the appeals that the
Supreme Court gets about 30 percent of
the total number come out of the Family
Division
so it's a small number in terms of the
gross number of cases but a lot of those
cases get appealed and 40 or so of those
are termination of parental rights cases
judge Garner talked about some cases
move quickly some take longer in 2014 we
had some law students for the summer and
we wanted to try to see if we could come
up with data points that were common
across divorce parenting cases that
caused them to be open longer than a
year so we looked at all of the cases
that were disposed between January and
December of 2014 which was 7 500 cases
roughly
of those cases 50 percent closed within
three months so from the time the case
was open the time it closed three months
seventy percent were closed within six
months 80 percent within nine months and
87 percent were closed within a year and
that's sort of our goal with a new
divorce cases from
open to disposition is a year we hope
that more than 90 percent close within
that time frame
um
most cases get resolved fairly quickly
in the Family Division
there are some that don't and that go on
for years there are some cases that have
hundreds and hundreds of pleadings those
are the cases that I think you've been
hearing about in some of those in your
committees and that's just the reality
of the circuit court it's not one size
doesn't fit all
um
so I think those are the numbers I
wanted to talk about
Mr chairman to anticipate another area
of Interest based on our conversation I
know Rules of Evidence and evidentiary
issues in Family Division has been a
concern to to the Committees so I would
like to ask judge Garner to discuss that
if that's
appropriate yes thank you judge thank
you
we think in terms of admissibility of
evidence and really that just means
what is the court allowed to consider
what is the court not going to consider
in terms of being a gatekeeper for what
we hope is going to be reliable evidence
the
question of the Rules of Evidence in
Family Division is as I understand the
subject of some proposed legislation so
let me try to give you a background and
if you'll indulge me I'll give you some
perspective in terms of what the reasons
might be
that might cause you to think carefully
about that sort of a proposal
currently the rules of evidence and I
brought my book with me it's a desk copy
that they give us we all have it
as lawyers we were trained in it from
law school and it is for those of us who
hear a lot of District division cases
criminal cases particularly everyone in
Superior Court
they live by the rules of evidence it's
a daily thing for them
in Family Division
it's not so much that way and
particularly in domestic relations cases
which are divorce parenting support
cases paternity
and I can lump domestic violence cases
in with that the Rules of Evidence don't
apply
and the Authority for that is a series
of Supreme Court decisions that actually
go back at least 80 years
and so there's a culture that these
sorts of cases do not receive the strict
treatment of the Rules of Evidence in
terms of the judge's decision whether to
admit certain evidence
or certain other kinds of evidence we
have discretion
the Family Division rules
carry on that that feature of our
practice that the Rules of Evidence
don't strictly apply but the Family
Division rules it's a rule 2.2 also
provide that the trial judge in their
discretion can utilize The Rules of
Evidence in order to create an orderly
predictable and fair kind of a
proceeding so that's available to us
in addition The Rules of Evidence
themselves carry a long list of
exemptions under a rule 1101 and among
those exemptions from The Rules of
Evidence are Domestic Relations cases so
that's the current law The Rules of
Evidence don't apply the court in in
some cases can use them but I would
suggest only consistent with an
agreement if there are attorneys
typically representing both sides
because the Rules of Evidence are
complicated
and their application is often highly
technical
and the results are not always intuitive
this makes them a challenge for folks
who are representing themselves and it
makes it a challenge for folks who are
represented by an attorney with a
self-represented litigant on the other
side
so
the cases that tell us that the Rules of
Evidence don't apply in these kinds of
cases don't embellish much about the
reasons why that should be
but I'll share with you my perspective
based on my experience about what those
reasons might be
first are the rules of evidence are
really a tool for trial lawyers
they're a tool to create a reliable
gatekeeping process so that the fact
finder typically a jury in those cases
have reliable evidence to consider and
don't have unreliable evidence
trial lawyers live by the rules of
evidence judges in jury courts and
judges in criminal cases including
judges in the district division in
Circuit Court apply the Rules of
Evidence have to be careful about them
and take that obligation very seriously
there are no juries in circuit court and
there are no juries in the Family
Division in circuit court and so at
least that part of it isn't really
necessary
Family Division cases and I'm thinking
mostly now Domestic Relations divorce
and parenting cases also have a couple
of unique features that I think
undermine the reason that might support
applying the rules of evidence in a
strict way the first of these is that
our court
tries its best to make our process user
friendly for those who are coming to
court for orders
and tries its best to make the process
as non-adversarial as possible partly
because often these folks who are in
front of the court on day one are going
to have parenting responsibilities for
children after the case is over and we
want to make sure that as difficult as
that case is for them we don't make it
more difficult by imposing on them
certain procedural strictures that they
may be unable to meet and that may
generate a result that at least they
will feel at some level wasn't a fair
result because of the application of
these rules
finally
divorce and parenting cases often take
um
often obligate the court to take into
account what's going to happen in the
future
if we're going to create a property
distribution or alimony or certainly
parenting orders that are going to be in
place from the time of the final decree
on we have to take a Long View in terms
of what's going to happen what are the
likelihoods what are the parents parties
expectations and planning for that sort
of a thing really doesn't have much to
do with what actually happened the Rules
of Evidence are designed to provide
reliable evidence about what actually
happened and that certainly is part of
what we have to do but it's not the
whole picture in these kinds of cases we
have to take into account some planning
element for the future for these parties
lives that are being deconstructed and
rearranged by this process
and the Rules of Evidence aren't
necessarily helpful for that we want to
give the parties the opportunity to tell
us what their concerns are to develop a
plan for the future and to provide
evidence that would support that plan
not necessarily evidence that would be
reliable to a fact finder but evidence
would be reliable for someone who's
planning the future of this family in
one way or another judge got him excuse
me for a minute being passed around to
some cards for members of the two
committees if they have questions as
well for them to write them down and
then when you have please send them back
and chairman Lynn is sorting them by
question type sorry sir carry on
wonderful thank you and I might add too
that um
Richard has my email so if you think of
something after the hearing that you
think I can weigh in on in terms of our
practice or our challenges or a court
process please let him know he'll send
it on to me I'll be more than happy to
respond
then
there are some practical reasons I think
that the imposition of the Rules of
Evidence might be of some concern to
those of us who hear these sorts of
cases in Family Division
particularly if you have a situation
where one party is represented by
Council and the other party is not
represented by Council the side that's
represented is going to start out with
some Advantage there if the Rules of
Evidence are being applied an attorney
May well have an obligation to their
client to try to take advantage of the
rules of evidence to the extent possible
that's part of our adversarial system
and there's nothing wrong with that
unless one party is so disadvantaged by
their lack of knowledge about the rules
or their lack of experience about the
rules that they simply are a target for
the imposition of the rules in a strict
way and requiring the rules to apply
makes it difficult for the court to
generate some kinds of information in
that context
further in the situation where both
parties are self-represented and that's
I think
rough guess more than 50 percent of our
cases divorce and parenting cases
involve folks who are representing
themselves each of them
applying the Rules of Evidence to those
sorts of cases creates what I think is
likely an insurmountable challenge for
them and it also begs the question of
who's going to
be the gatekeeper there in a very
practical way
if one party is testifying in a way or
submitting evidence
that is clearly contrary to The Rules of
Evidence
the judge is faced with a choice if the
other party is not objecting does the
court weigh in and say you can't do that
that feels to the party reasonably feels
to the party as though the Court's
simply not in interested in listening to
what they have to say or in considering
their evidence
so there are sort of a myriad of
practical problems that go along with
that as someone who is trained in the
rules and who
worked with the rules as an attorney
doing trials and as someone who still
applies the rules in District division
in criminal cases
I have tremendous respect for the rules
of evidence and I think there's a role
for them I'm concerned that the strict
imposition of the Rules of Evidence May
extend our cases these sorts of cases in
Family Division may not really be a good
fit for these sorts of cases in Family
Division and will create impediments and
costs to the parties both in terms of
the time and in terms of some
dissatisfaction with the result if it if
it appears to them that the result is
based on a technical application
they're not going to be happy about the
results if it appears and I think
studies that we've learned about have
shown this if the parties feel as though
the process is fair they've been
listened to they've been understood the
court is taken into account their
concerns and their own point of view
then the outcome is slightly less
critical to them it's the process itself
that we're trying to make as Fair as
possible to these folks who are often
representing themselves and the in my
view the marginal benefit of imposing
The Rules of Evidence is probably
outweighed in the long term
by the the difficulties that it creates
for folks within that system and the
difficulties it creates in achieving the
goals that we'd like to try to meet
so that's my practical take I want to
clarify that I'm not speaking on behalf
of the judicial branch this is this is
my read based on my experience judge
Gunner um
chairman Lynn has been sorting the cards
by type and I've asked him if he has
cards on this particular issue of Rules
of Evidence this would be a good time to
take questions on that subject you just
spoke of thank you
I might mention while he's sorting
through those cards that if you have
questions about the Rules of Evidence
um generally and even specifically
I don't consider myself an expert in the
Rules of Evidence by any means but you
have an expert sitting here in this room
and I suspect that representative Lynn
would be more than happy to sort of give
you the Practical impact of the Rules of
Evidence at any level
well thank you I wonder how quickly I
would be reversed though but yeah
so you know I um I guess I would um
in trying to follow up on what you were
just speaking of um judge Garner
um one one questioner says if the rules
of evidence do not do not apply then
does the court rely on hearsay
in its orders
um and I wonder if you could maybe just
elaborate on that a bit it's a
complicated answer and and I don't like
to say maybe but
if the Rules of Evidence don't apply the
court has discretion to determine what's
relevant and to determine what's
material and helpful to the court in
making its decision
there are on and I should mention just
by way of background that
hearsay is a vast part of the Rules of
Evidence so even applying the Rules of
Evidence there are some statements that
are not hearsay because of the reason
that they're offered and there are a
long list of exceptions to the rule
against hearsay which cover many of the
kinds of evidence that people would
submit that would be admissible even
Under The Rules of Evidence
I'll tell you when my personal take is
when I have a hearsay objection I'm
going to be guided by the rules to begin
with if it's not hearsay then I'm going
to overrule the objection if it is
hearsay I'll run through in my head what
the exceptions might be
and if there are no exceptions that
particularly cover it I'll ask myself
what are the independent indicio
reliability about this particular piece
of evidence whether it's a statement or
whether it's a document is there
something about it either the context or
the content or plugging it into that
piece of the case it makes it reliable
in a way that we wouldn't ordinarily
rely on on a blank statement
and if it is then I'll probably let it
in so the answer is that hearsay some
kinds of hearsay is admissible is
admissible under the rules under one of
the exceptions and I don't expect that
the Family Division in these sorts of
cases
would allow um
would disallow evidence that would come
in under the rules I think if anything
we're going to expand a little bit
beyond the rules to get information that
we're greedy for frankly in in looking
to make good decisions and to help these
folks for the rest of their lives so
that's my maybe answer okay thank you
um and let me just address this to
really all any of you who may want to
answer it the question is without Rules
of Evidence how do you address possible
mental health concerns
as related to the best interest of the
child
uh in making custody and or parenting
time decisions
sure
I think actually there's some potential
for the Rules of Evidence to be an
impediment to that sort of an inquiry
medical records of
therapy or counseling records those
sorts of things
are often the best evidence that might
bear on that kind of a question
and the Rules of Evidence might
sometimes exclude those because of the
lack of a foundation or a lack of
authentication whereas if the parties
agree that a document is something that
it is what it purports to be and it's
relevant then the court would typically
take that into account and probably
allow it to be marked and probably
consider it I should mention as a
footnote because we're talking about
medical or counseling records that the
provisions of the rules of evidence that
relate to privileges
attorney-client privilege doctor patient
privileged counselor therapist privilege
those carry on and those are applied
even in the cases where the Rules of
Evidence don't strictly apply so there
may be issues related to privilege that
might keep something out of that nature
but the authentication issues were
likely to get past if the parties agree
that the document is what it is
um this is a little a little bit
different but I think it generally goes
to the sort of the issues of efficiency
in the judicial branch and the and I'm
I'm sort of recasting the question but
uh this questioner raises concerns about
um
delays in family cases and
uh particularly focuses on the fact that
apparently that that in many cases the
the presiding judge
changes
um during the course of the proceeding
here it is the ledge two or three times
during the course of a proceeding could
you just kind of any of you really just
sort of explain what when in a
particular case is it normally assigned
to a particular judge throughout the
case or is it or does the judge do the
judges change hearing to hearing and if
so when when is that likely to happen
yeah so in a perfect world
representative Lynn
a Family Division was designed to be one
family one judge so the the concept was
a judge would be assigned to a case and
it would be if there was a divorce case
pending that it would be the judge if
there was a related abuse neglect that
would be the same judge there was a
juvenile delinquency case would be the
same judge but the reality is that we
have a lot of turnover in our bench we
have to move judges around because
on any given day I may get a call in the
morning or the night before that a judge
is out for covet or other related
reasons and we have to shuffle judges
around so
I think in a best case scenario it would
be a judge that would carry through the
life of the case but some of these cases
go on for years and years too so a judge
May retire and somebody else has to come
in I just had a case literally that was
the case had been pending for 20 years
the judge retired and one of the lawyers
asked that the judge be specially
assigned in his retirement to hear the
case and I said because he's because the
judge had been hearing this case for 20
years they said he's retired I mean I
can't force him to come out of
retirement to hear this case
um that's an extreme example but the
reality is that with a turnover and
judges and judges covering multiple
locations that it's it's not possible to
have one judge for one case straight
through from beginning to end and you
know just to sort of follow up in this
because I think that that's um there are
a number of questions here that sort of
focus on how long Family Division cases
take and I know you mentioned before
that that the typical and perhaps uh the
vast majority of let's say divorce cases
are concluded within a year can you just
give us without getting into the details
of any particular case but can you just
give us sort of a um an overview of of
what what are the situations that cause
a case to go on for like 20 years as you
just said what are the what are the sort
of dynamics of the situation that causes
that kind of thing to happen and what
and it's and is there something the
judge can do to stop that yeah I'll let
judge Garner handle it yeah
I I can't think of any off-handed or 20
years but
but I think every judge who works in the
Family Division has cases that have gone
on longer than they should have gone on
in the ideal world
some of those cases too are cases in
which you've gotten to a final hearing
within the period you would hope
certainly six months nine months a year
if it's a really contested case
final orders have been entered but the
case may have been brought forward by
one of the parties
and this that's not something we can
control there are legal standards that
in parenting issues that make the burden
of proof more difficult if you bring a
case forward from a final parenting plan
but that doesn't prevent folks from
bringing them forward and there are
quite legitimate and reasonable issues
too such as a proposed relocation of the
children's residents that could prompt
the case to be brought forward so I
think it's important to distinguish
between the question of how long the
Family Division gets to a final decree
the first time the case is filed and
then how we manage a case once it's
brought forward because it can be
brought forward it seems endlessly I'm
sure it seems endless to the parties but
it can be brought forward almost at
infinitum until typically the children
reach age of 18.
um I would say that there are a couple
of issues that tend to come up that may
cause some delays inherently
if the parties are having trouble
managing the exchange of information we
have a mandatory Discovery rule
sometimes it's difficult for folks to
get around to doing that
if the parties are
at loggerheads in terms of the parenting
orders even if there are temporary
orders in place if they're having
trouble complying or their motions for
contempt about non-compliance that can
always delay the process because we'll
schedule a hearing on those motions once
the motion and objection is filed
it happens sometimes that um in
complicated cases particularly
complicated Financial cases you'll have
attorneys on both sides they have to do
a lot of Discovery in those cases they
may have to engage experts to testify to
provide opinions that process in itself
tends to take longer than the case might
otherwise require those are inherent
issues with every case and the faces of
them change and there are always cases
that have a combination of more than one
of those features that just make it
difficult to say to the parties and have
them say to the court now we're ready
now we're ready to schedule a final
hearing we've done what we have to do
we're prepared let's go forward and
typically the court is not
likely we're going to try to time the
scheduling of a final hearing at a point
where we can trust that the parties are
really ready and they need the time
because if
if the case really doesn't need a full
day and we schedule a full day and it
turns out that day or the day before
that it didn't need a full day and
they've settled it we've just spent a
day that we may not be able to fill in
with other hearings so we we treat our
time as valuable and we try to get the
litigants to look at it the same way and
everyone tries to be practical and
realistic about how long the case will
take let me follow up on that from
another card on the subject we're on
right now in terms of a length of time
we already spoke of there were not
enough judges we it looks like are going
to get some more of the ones we need but
what about one of the litigants who's
churning the process whether it is the
wealthy person who can pay a lawyer to
tie the other one up with endless
motions or somebody who is pro se but
has read too much and doesn't understand
enough and is doing the same thing when
is it proper for the judge to come in
and say you're abusing the process
in that situation once it becomes
apparent that one side or the other is
is dragging their heels
the Court's primary focus is going to be
on setting deadlines to get the
discovery complete once the discovery is
complete there's really there should be
no impediment to scheduling a final
hearing and when they've completed
Discovery they know what the issues are
going to be and they can tell us if they
need a two-hour final hearing or half a
day or a full day final hearing so the
court I think has an obligation at some
point in the in that's in that stage
when that's becoming apparent to begin
to schedule hearings to set those
deadlines to make sure that if there are
if there's a need for orders on
Discovery those orders get out right
away and the parties know what their
face it I think most attorneys who are
experienced in this area will tell you
that
the prime time to settle cases is when
you get that final hearing schedule
that's what you're preparing for for the
client there that's when the expenses
are going to go up that's when the
uncertainty can be nipped in the bud by
a settlement and that's the best time to
settle the cases and we're always
looking for ways to get them close to
that moment the follow-up to that is
that if family and divorce issues are
not that legislatively mandated priority
is one of the ways to speed up a divorce
case for the legislature to make that a
mandatory priority with a follow-up I'll
put in but if everything becomes
mandated nothing is then pretty soon
I don't disagree with that last part of
it it's really a policy question whether
you impose those sorts of deadlines on
us in terms of those cases but
in my experience because of the
unpredictability of the cases and really
the wide spectrum
I think there are likely cases that that
could never be done
properly and fully Within
any sort of mandated time constraint
there will be those exceptions as judge
king mentioned most of our cases get
resolved one way or the other we funnel
folks into mediation through the first
appearance program that's been very
successful particularly in resolving the
parenting cases that's a that's a high
priority for us is to get folks into
that process of working together to try
to settle the cases as early as we can
it's just these outlier cases that are
extremely difficult for whatever reason
extremely time consuming those are going
to be very difficult to manage within a
mandated period of time
thank you I wonder if these two sort of
related questions the first uh is would
better training of Circuit Court judges
reduce the hours needed by judges to
deal with contested family cases
um
uh by by reducing the need for
re-hearings that kind of thing and then
the second sort of related question is
can you uh
uh
take just a bit of time to explain to us
the the uh the evaluation process of
Judges how judges are evaluated and how
often that happens that kind of thing
foreign
the first question deals with training
and
um that's responsibility of the
administrative office and we don't have
a one-size-fits-all for judicial
training sometimes we'll get two or
three judges at once uh and we can put
together a more robust training program
we're in the process right now of
training Judge Amy Manchester she got
appointed as a one-off judge and so
we've cobbled together a training
schedule for her
um it's it's harder to bring in outside
resources for one judge but we we can
never do enough training we do a
Judicial training every other month for
all of our judges in the Circuit Court
could be a topic of any of the three
divisions we don't have money to hire
outside presenters so we do our own
homemade presentations using our judges
and staff attorneys and Outsiders as we
can get them but I think we can always
do more training the second question was
could you
yeah that's a creature of Statute we're
required every three years to do a
evaluation of all of our judges uh we
had a committee that took a deep dive a
few years ago representative Smith was
on the committee uh we changed the
instrument that we use to do the
evaluations we now do them
electronically using SurveyMonkey and we
Post in the courthouses and in bar news
when a certain group of Judges is being
evaluated and it's open to anyone who
wants to complete the evaluation we
typically get anywhere from 30 to 50
evaluations back for a judge and then
it's my job to analyze those and go
through them with the judge and use
those as a tool to help performance
going forward
by and large the judicial and the
results not by judge but the results
each year are made available to the
governor's office office the House and
Senate and are on our website in terms
of how many judges were evaluated what
the mean and median scores were for all
judges and by and large our judges even
the judges in the Family Division do
pretty well on their performance
evaluations
yes
as someone who's been through that
process quite a bit I would just point
out that
uh judges don't often get feedback about
how they're doing
that just for whatever reason
um
we're somewhat isolated and attorneys
particularly aren't going to come up and
tell us often that we've done a terrible
job and this is really what we need to
refocus on and maybe get some training
on
there is a component of the evaluation
that's a self-evaluation and I've always
found that extremely valuable because it
gives me a chance to sort of second
guess what I've been doing and maybe
identify areas that I can do better and
I think we're still doing it the
evaluation process generates
a series of particular comments from the
evaluators they've been edited so
they're sort of anonymous but comments
that can be really helpful for a judge
reading over and understanding how
someone else perceived how they did
their job for me both of those
components
um
sort of take the edge off what otherwise
might be sort of an anxious process of
getting evaluated but it does generate
great information it's helpful for us in
our efforts to do our job better
thank you that's a parallel to that
could you speak to
um the judicial review I mean this this
is a bit of training but I mean the
disciplinary process
of when it is alleged that a judge has
really crossed the line
so I'm not sure if I understand the
question Mr chairman but there were
there were two two avenues that that can
go if I know a situation where there is
an allegation that the judges in an
order made an error of law
that goes to Chief Justice McDonald's
court and they review that as part of
the Appellate process and they either
affirm the judge or they reverse the
judge the second component deals more
with behavioral issues on the part of a
judge which is maybe what you're getting
at there is a Judicial conduct committee
uh Robert middleholtzer is the chairman
of that it has a number of members both
from the public and the court system and
they meet monthly and they review
complaints if you will against judges
and I I get copies of all of them as
they make their way through to the end
of the process and by and large
most of the complaints against judges
that I see in the Circuit Court are
Judges who sit in primarily in the
Family Division they involve mostly
divorce parenting cases and for the most
part they go to the merits of the case
that the you know the judge came up with
the wrong decision if you will which is
really something that should go to the
Appellate Court if that's the issue if
it rises to a serious enough level it's
it becomes a public complaint and
there's a whole process for that for the
judicial conduct committee and they too
report their findings at the end of
every year how many complaints they
received how many resulted in certain
outcomes so that's that's a public and
transparent process the complaints are
confidential until they erase the level
of a complaint by the committee could
you try to remember a recent year and
give us the number of complaints and the
number that were
dismissed for not being what would go
forward with any action I I'm losing the
term I'm striving for here yeah since
that's a that's a function that's
outside of the judicial branch I don't
have those numbers at hand I I they are
available there's a link on the Supreme
on our judicial branch website to the
judicial conduct committee and I think
those statistics are available but I'll
follow up and see if I can get the most
recent report
but this is an external it sounds like
when you said you didn't have that
information that means this is somewhat
of an external
Review Committee it is external to the
judicial branch it's not the guys
evaluating their themselves correct okay
uh this is this is I think an important
topic would you please talk about
mediation and its effect on caseloads
and the weighted caseload study are
there impediments to structural
mediation such as not enough mediators
or insufficient funding
so I can start and maybe judge Garner
can talk more specifically about Family
Division the office of mediation and
arbitration Works uh out of the judicial
branch and we have mediation pretty much
across all case types some are available
at no charge to litigants some have a
sliding scale I think in the Family
Division and I think all judges strongly
encourage various forms of alternative
dispute resolution mediation being the
primary one it's required in all cases
involving parenting cases where the
parents are required to go to mediation
pretty much out of the gate to try to
get those issues resolved and it's
highly effective I mean the the success
rates are are pretty high in the Circuit
Court we also have something called
neutral case evaluation
which has kind of fallen off because we
rely on judicial officers to do it but
neutral case evaluation is where a judge
who is not going to hear the case sits
down for a half day or a day with the
parties depending on the complexity of
the case and you sort of have a almost a
mini trial without Witnesses and at the
end of the process the judge tells the
parties how he or she thinks if they
were to have heard the case it would
come out so just for example you know
let's say it's an alimony issue at the
end the judge says you know I think this
is a situation where if I were the judge
hearing this case based on what I've
heard I would be ordering alimony it may
be a case where the lawyer's been
telling his or her client you're going
to pay alimony and they're saying no I'm
not and the lawyer's saying yes you are
and so you go to neutral case evaluation
and experienced judicial officer you
know being versed in the law and having
heard the facts
says what they think would happen
sometimes that is a really good way to
get those more difficult cases to settle
I did a neutral case evaluation during
covid in a trust docket case that
involved multi-millions of dollars we
had lots of lawyers we started at 8 30
in the morning I left the law office at
8 30 that night it was a Friday night we
spent 12 hours and ultimately and this
was a case that had gone to mediation
and and didn't settle ultimately because
I was a judge and I have experience in
this area of the law
and I was able to tell the parties what
I think is going to happen in this case
including how the legal fees which were
in the millions of dollars might get
apportioned if I were to hear the case
the parties were able to work with their
lawyers and get that case resolved
that case was scheduled for an eight-day
trial in two weeks and so I called the
judge when I got home that night and
said you owe me one because I just
settled an eight-day trial for you but
neutral case evaluation is a very good
tool and we would like to expand that in
the Family Division as we have the
resources to do it
part of it let me just supplement a
little bit with a specific procedure
that applies in divorce cases with
children and parenting cases
when the petition is filed and assuming
that there are no emergency orders that
are involved the parties are sent to
what we call the first appearance
session
pre-covered we were doing these sessions
live so typically in the courtroom where
I'm able to sit in Laconia we can seat
about 25 people we'd have 10 or 12
couples come in and they would get
directly from me or from whatever judge
was doing at that day a basic
description of the process the procedure
of this involved mention of the
mandatory Discovery Rule and a lot of
information about mediation and the
presumption is and was from that process
that unless there was a reason to be
exempt from it the parties would go to
mediation before they would come back to
court for any contested hearings and we
had great success at that I should
mention as a footnote that there is an
exception for cases where there's a
domestic violence protective order in
effect in those cases we can send the
parties to mediation but only if they
both agree either one of them gets a
veto power and those mediation sessions
always occur at the courthouse we've
been doing the first appearance
questions remotely now because there's a
video that the judicial branch created
for us we've candidly with speakers who
are a lot more effective at it than I
was doing it live although I still think
there was some benefit to having it live
but it's been a great program and our
mediators
in a place like Laconia we've been using
the same mediators for years and they
are fully expert at what they do and
they're very nice people and they create
an atmosphere there's much more
congenial and productive than the sort
of formal courtroom atmosphere that
they're going to be facing if the
mediation doesn't work out so it's been
a great program and we completely
encourage it
so this I
one of the questions I think this is
this is a a point that needs to be made
can you just explain to us let's talk
about I'm not talking about part-time
judges but a full-time judge can you
just explain our full-time judges
permitted to have any other employment
and are there any are there limits on a
judge's ability to earn income
outside of his or her judicial salary
uh
there is a limitation judges are allowed
to do
teaching I think is pretty much the only
outside employment that they're allowed
to do only with the permission written
permission of the Chief Justice and
their salary cannot exceed I think it's
15 of the judge's salary
um I just I can tell you from experience
the Circuit Court judges don't have time
to teach
um
I don't I'm not sure if we have any uh
active I think we may have some judges
who teach uh trial ad at the law school
some Superior Court judges and I think
we might have one circuit court judge
that does it but it's pretty Limited
can't practice law at all under rule 38
which is the code of judicial conduct
I want to follow up on the judicial
conduct committee uh the questionnaire
and I don't know if this is correct or
not I'll just read the card why do the
members of the judicial conduct
committee number one not have to take an
oath of office I'm not sure what that
means and secondly and I know the answer
to this one had there why do they have
their meetings in secret
well by rule the process is confidential
unless as I said earlier the complaint
the the cases risen to the level of a
complaint I have no idea whether they
take an oath of office or not
okay I don't know why they
I don't know why they would but they not
I don't know that they do or don't in
terms of meetings in secret
if I was accused of something I would
want it to be substantiated before I
read about it in the union later
you know you wouldn't read about in the
union leader until it was risen to the
level of the complaint and then the
process is the judge gets the complaint
and has 30 days to respond to it and
then the committee sort of takes off
from there so at the end of the case the
judge always gets a copy and the
resolution but
um you wouldn't want a judge to know in
the middle of a case that someone would
file a complaint so there's two sides to
that thank you
so
um
this this uh the questioner asks why are
Judges not ending cases
um sooner and allowing frivolous motions
um that's that's the question I so I put
it to to you uh you know what is that is
that true and uh what what you know what
why what are the processes for for sort
of
truncating cases that seem to go on
forever
the question of frivolity I think may be
something that's uh in the eye of the
beholder
but we have an obligation to move the
cases along and to provide good orders
within a reasonable and fair period of
time
and so to the extent that motions to us
appear to be frivolous
will typically make a finding we may
make immediate rulings on those sorts of
motions so to convey the message at some
point in the process I think we have
authority although I think it's rarely
used
to limit A party's right to file
additional motions I don't know that
we're ever going to be able to justify
preventing a party from filing some
things that's an access to justice issue
that is really fundamental to what we do
but we can impose sanctions and we can
impose requirements on filings that will
to some degree enhance the likelihood
that the Motions are not going to be
frivolous in terms of resolving the
cases sooner
I think there are two processes there
one is the process of our workload so
currently if you were to have a
pre-trial conference with us today and
you needed a full day final hearing
we're scheduling about three months out
of it so that's that's time you're going
to wait to get to that hearing with
nothing else going on
but there are also
cases in which we can intervene if you
will or help the parties uh in a
direction of mediation or neutral case
evaluation that may help the case get
resolved sooner it's in our interest and
it's certainly in the party's interests
to get cases resolved as soon as they
can be fairly resolved meaning that all
the relevant information is available to
them to present and meaning that they've
exhausted all the possibilities of
negotiation
so I think we have a common goal with
folks in that our workload is a bit of
an impediment in terms of the time we
have available and the nature of some of
the cases makes it basically challenging
to get them ready for a final Hearing in
a in a brief period of time
I wonder if the next question which I
think judge Garner you may have touched
on this a little bit earlier but
um could you could any of you really
give us your thoughts on what what would
be the effect
if that's a general matter in family law
cases the burden of proof were elevated
in other words instead of preponderance
of the evidence which is generally the
standard that applies it were elevated
to either clear and convincing evidence
or proof Beyond A Reasonable Doubt what
can you just tell us what your sense of
what the effect of that would be
the clear and convincing standard is
already in place in cases that are
brought forward on parenting issues so
under 461a 11 1 at least two of those
subsections require clear and convincing
evidence before the court can modify an
existing parenting plan so it's not a
standard that we're unused to
it's a I think a difficult standard to
articulate for uh for parties who are
self-represented
and
um
to some degree the there is no
particular burden of proof in the first
the first time around in Family Division
cases there's a presumption of joint
decision making there's a presumption
that regular and frequent contact with
children is consistent with their best
interests and the standard for orders
that relate to Children is what's in the
best interest of the child rather than a
formal assignment of burden of proof to
one side or the other
so I think it starts with a More Level
Playing Field if
there's no reason in my view to require
parties both to prove something by
clearing convincing evidence the first
time around the statutory standard in
for modification of parenting is there
because the legislature recognized that
stability is really important for
children they wanted to make it a little
more difficult for someone seeking to
modify a parenting plan to come back and
and get a modification so they impose
that standard under those two
subsections
so beyond a reasonable doubt I I won't
address that I
I don't know how that would work
the next question I I think this is
really a this is a valid one why did the
court system not request in the budget
the number of Judges indicated by the
weighted case study
[Music]
it is a valid question
um
we we and I want to be clear this is we
our request this year is a significant
step towards addressing or uh needs but
it's not the final step and we're also
mindful of the larger context in which
we operate and we try to be good
partners in state government and uh good
stewards of the taxpayers dollars
um and all of those factors played into
our ultimate decision to ask for seven
in the circuit court and one in the
Superior Court
thank you
um and and you know by the time we're
developing our next budget we'll have
better we'll have
good insight as to hopefully or how our
additional resources are helping our
caseload and we'll be able to come back
to the legislature again informed with
with whether what what further
additional needs we have
can um I wonder uh maybe this would be
for you judge king of the of the 126
000 or so uh circuit court cases can you
give us a rough idea of approximately
how many are
dcyf related in other words that have
the division
uh children for children youth and
families involved uh at some level
so you
talking pretty much about abuse neglect
and and delinquency cases
um and so I'll use uh 2020 two numbers
uh
[Music]
looks like about
2600 cases in 2022 would have involved
the division directly
well and then there's another 560
determination of parental rights cases
which that's sort of the back end of the
abuse neglect typically so
um north of 3000 cases
thank you
yep
I think on slide eight if you look at
the Circle to identified as juvenile
yep identifies the number of case
juvenile related cases for the years
that we use for the little kids load
study
um the next question uh do judges still
order
parent-child unification therapy and if
so why why or why not
thank you
[Music]
that process is not currently
unavailable to us
but there are some elements of the
process that make it extremely rare
if I understand the process it is that a
reunification therapist
is appointed presumably with the consent
of the parties but by order of the Court
to conduct a reunification therapy to
allow and enhance and encourage a child
to reunify with one parent the question
of the word reunification is a bit
ambiguous whether it means just some
regular contact or whether it means a
full reunification under a shared
residential schedule but it's a process
in which typically there are there's a
therapist or the child
there may be a therapist for the parent
but there's a reunification therapist
who provides the Forum and provides some
of the therapy and helps all of them
work together to try to reunify their
relationship
because it is
an intense pretty intense process it's I
think rarely used it's probably an
expensive process and I'll say as a
caveat I've never had a case where I've
actually presided over the process
although
um
is not completely unknown to me because
of some things that have come up in
other cases but I won't mention
specifically but it's a
it's a process in which I think some of
the therapists have great faith and it
would be
just thinking globally it would be
something that would be used in the rare
occasion and often as virtually a last
resort when the relationship between a
parent and a child for whatever reason
is so distant and so is strange that
without professional input and
professional assistance it may not be
salvageable
so that's my quick take I'll know more
if I ever get to a series of hearings
that involve that but that's my
understanding of the process and and
some of the pitfalls
uh judge king I think this probably
would be the best the best address to
you um
you mentioned I think earlier in your
remarks that uh there were no more
marital Masters um on the bench um
uh they that that many of them had
retired and then I apparently at some
point at some point later you mentioned
that um uh some marital masses had
become judges in fact I think judge
Garner so could you just can you just
kind of explain how I mean is it is that
a
a sort of usual course or when we did
have marital Masters was it was is that
something that you know to go from being
a marital Master to a judge to something
that happened in with some some
regularity
I think it was probably unheard of until
we created the Circuit Court back when
the Superior Court had jurisdiction over
divorces before you cleverly pass them
on to us
um
I think the marital Masters were
creation of the Superior Court initially
because the judges didn't want to hear
marital cases so they found a way to
have someone else hear them and then as
we rolled the Family Division out on by
Statute we began to inherit the superior
Court's marital Masters until July 1st
2011 as I said there were 13 left we got
them all
as part of House Bill 609 which was the
bill that created the Circuit Court in
2011 uh
under speaker O'Brien there was a
provision put into 490f that said as a
marital Masters term expires and they
were they were appointed for five-year
terms
or they retired they couldn't they they
would be converted to a Judicial
position as the budget allowed there
were three marital Masters in that one
year that 2011 window
whose terms expired David Forrest and
barber and Phil cross
those three marital Masters were
terminated their their positions were
ended and Barbara went into the
practices of law day Force I think
taught at Keen for a while and Phil
cross became a mediator
the next but the next session of the
legislature we went back and we said can
we change that because that seems unfair
can we change it to when a judge retires
um or is not reappointed that the
position would convert and the statute
was amended so that marital Masters
terms could be extended if they wanted
to stay over the course of time marital
Mass has retired some then did apply to
become judges including judge Garner
judge craw Phil cross applied for a
Judicial position he's now a judge Dave
Forrest is a judge Jen Lemire who I
think this committee's heard from on a
couple of occasions is a judge Bob Foley
was a marital Master he became a judge
he's now a retired judge
did I miss anyone
okay and so Tom Cooper was the last
marital Master to retire he retired last
year and he is the one mayoral master
that still sits very occasionally he's
been great to cover for us when we've
had a coveted illness or something he's
gone in and covered dockets for us but
we're we basically have no more marital
Masters left
um why so
um
with the f um
with the efforts of Juvenile Diversion
do you see a reduction in uh the time
that that circuit court judges are
spending on juvenile related cases
so judge Ashley's the expert on that
she's the deputy administrative judge
and I know only from speaking with her
that the number of cases that actually
become cases now is has been decreased
dramatically because of the requirement
to have an evaluation done before the
charge can be filed and I think that's
made a big difference and I think it's
keeping a lot of kids out of court that
otherwise would find themselves tied up
in the in the judicial system I think
it's been a I think she would say it's
been a big success
I wonder if you could talk generally
about the use of guardian ad litem
Guardians Adel item in uh in family law
cases
before the Circuit Court came into being
Guardians ad litem were I think more
numerous than they are currently
there was a period of time when we had a
state fund that would pay some of the
fees for Guardians I'd Litem for folks
who were eligible for those kinds of
services
part of the creation of the Circuit
Court was to emphasize mediation as a
way to resolve cases and I think the
theory was that if cases were mediated
and resolved by agreement between the
parties we wouldn't need Guardians I'd
like them to the extent that they were
sort of the rule of the day in the days
when these cases were heard in Superior
Court there are still Guardians at Litem
who are practicing there are not nearly
as many as there were and the state fund
that used to pay for their fees for
eligible parties is now hasn't been in
place for a number of years
so they potentially have a role to play
as a as a judge who hears a lot of these
cases and as someone who did Guardian Ad
Litem work when I was in private
practice I think there's a role for them
they can be very helpful in the right
case they are
simply because of the finances only now
available to folks who can afford to pay
for their fees
and those fees can be significant
particularly Guardians ad litem who were
practicing attorneys will they may not
charge exactly what they would charge a
private client but
um they need to charge enough money to
make the work attractive to them and
that's what they do so we have Guardians
that light them available in Laconia
we've got three or four on a list they
get some cases but we always have to be
very careful with the parties to let
them know that the fees are on them and
and there's no other way to pay for
those Services I could go into
endless detail about the role and the
history but I think the short answer is
that Guardians at Litem are available
but only to a certain select few of our
of our litigants
why are the members of family law
committee not required to serve a number
of hours observing what really happens
in court stay tuned we're going on field
trips
thank you
uh
this question I think is
um I I think it's probably something
that would be important to discuss
um can you just whoever would be the
most uh the most appropriate one to
answer this but can you just talk
generally about the effect of delay
in in coming to an accurate you know an
accurate decision in the case in other
words you know we've we're obviously the
As Time Goes By memories fade that kind
of thing but in the particularly in the
family law context
um can you can you talk about that a
little bit how delay and and uh and
having cases adjudicated how that can
affect the accuracy of of fact finding
you mean delay during the process of
getting to the final hearing or delay
after the final hearings taken place
well I guess both really maybe uh but
but probably more more the former than
the latter but really both
most of our divorce cases are based on
irreconcilable differences now there are
foregrounds available but they're rarely
pled and rarely uh hotly litigated and
so the question of delay comes up
if there are changes in values for a
property that's going to be distributed
for example the parties separate and a
year later the house is worth something
different than it was that can create an
issue for parties depending on how the
market is doing
there is delay affects children
in practical ways children whose parents
have separated and whose future with
either parent may be a little bit
uncertain creates anxiety and problems
for them behavioral problems for them
that's sort of a dramatic impact of of
the delay in the process
some delay in the process is inherent
because the parties still need to
reassess what they have and and do their
Discovery and be prepared for a final
hearing and and to look into negotiated
settlement but delay in the process is
almost
never a good thing unless something is
happening in the meantime to help the
parties toward resolution so if a case
is going to go out several months
without anything being scheduled we'll
talk to the parties about using the rest
of their mediation time
if they haven't used all of their
mediation time or we might arrange for a
neutral case evaluation once the
discovery is done to give them a handle
on what to expect so it is um
detrimental to the parties emotionally
it can be detrimental to the family and
it can may it can make valuation issues
taking place months after the moment of
separation more difficult for the court
but really more the former than the
latter we can manage the valuation
issues already it's the it's the sort of
ongoing anxiety and
chronic emotional outfall that we really
worry about for folks
and I should say that's true after the
final hearing has taken place too that's
a terrible time for folks to be waiting
for their orders and we would always
like to get the orders out as soon as
possible as soon as we can review the
evidence write the order and be
thoughtful and careful about it
so I wonder if this really addressed to
to uh to any of you but um as you I
think as you both as you've met some of
you have reflected on before
um
the family cases it was my experience
when I was in the judicial branch and
I'm sure it's your family cases are the
ones that tend to generate the most
complaints to us as legislators to the
judicial conduct committee
um you know complaints in the media that
kind I wonder if you could and I should
say my understanding and correct me if
things have changed in the last three
and a half years but the overwhelming
majority of complaints that are made to
the judicial conduct Committee in family
cases are found to be non-meritorious
there are that's not to say all of them
but but the vast majority of them
but I wonder if you could offer any
insights as to why you think that is
that that um
family cases in particular tend to
generate so much angst
I'll just talk generically and I'm not
the expert on the marital law as judge
Garner as if I've been a judge for 33
years nobody would want me hearing the
divorce case it's outside of my area of
expertise but I do review all of the
complaints because I get them at the end
of the process and I think they're just
there as you well know representative
Linda High emotion cases people are very
set in their ways they feel very
strongly about their position for good
reasons and when the case doesn't go the
way they wanted to then the they're
angry at the judge they're angry at the
process they file appeals they file
complaints and
we they want us to make their lives
better and that's and we just don't have
that ability to put their lives back
together that the judges just can't do
that and you know as you heard divorce
cases in the Superior Court when you
were judged I worked with judge
Manchester this morning we were going
over the code of judicial conduct and
we're talking about
um disqualification and we're talking
about the judicial conduct committee and
the Tapley case is the case that we
train on and that was your case that
went to the Supreme Court and I think
you had
four if not five JCC complaints filed
against you in that case and you stayed
with the case because you felt you
didn't have a conflict in the Supreme
Court affirmed you but you you certainly
have a sense for how emotionally
draining these cases are and how people
you know sometimes file complaints out
of out of anger because the case didn't
go the way they wanted it to go
I gotta read it our judges paid a salary
or is there a financial incentive for
them to hear more emotions in a case
so I can answer that question I think
everyone don't mind Mr chairman I'll go
back and just add something to the
previous the answer is yes we are paid a
salary and no there is no Financial
incentive for us to have more motions
fine
ask
um I just wanted to add that
I think some of the difficulties
um
that are inherent with Family Division
cases and particularly parenting cases
come about because
the relationship typically at one time
was a good relationship between the
parties if they have children or if
they've been married for a long time and
now
something's gone wrong sometimes
something terribly wrong so there's a
history and there's a sense from the
parties that they're looking back and
they're asking the court to look back
throughout the course of what may have
been a very long-term relationship with
ups and downs but carrying forward as a
team and now they're not a team anymore
so there's a real emotional component
there there's also the sense I think
from litigants who are involved in these
cases that their whole world in terms of
where they live what they do what they
can rely on for finances
is being turned upside down and in some
ways is being shaken by the process to
see what sorts out and
finally if it's a contested parenting
issue there's nothing that touches
people more closely than their
relationship with their children
and that's at risk and they find
themselves in a process that's sort of
foreign to them in terms of the
terminology and the forms and someone
from their point of view is reaching out
to change that relationship that they
have with their children it's it's not a
Wonder to me at all that it's a very
intense emotional kind of a process all
we can do is try to make it as Fair as
we can and and let the parties do as
much as they can Empower them to do as
much as they can to try to resolve their
cases on their own it's their children
it's their lives we really don't want to
be rearranging those things if we don't
have to and if they can do it so we
encourage that but it doesn't make the
cases much easier
before we listen to the final few
questions I want everybody to know that
we will be adjourning at 4 30 or in your
terms to billable hours
and uh
no they get us they get a salary I know
so um we'll have a few more questions
and any of you who may stay please do
and we'll hang out and ask you private
questions
you know uh this question I'm I'm I'm
altering it just a little bit to make it
maybe a little bit broader to capture
what I think are is a matter that that
I've heard issues on
um people raising questions about
um can you explain the process for uh by
which the uh the record is made uh when
when a case is being heard
uh how a party can get a copy of the of
the record
um and if there are you know if the
party is Indigent are there funds
available to to to Aid that process and
when if ever is the wreck is a record
not made
first thing I do when we get new judges
is tell them that the record you do not
want to do anything that's not on the
record the old days when we practice law
on Spirit core a lot was done in
Chambers law was done off the record
deals were made
we tell our new judges everything is
done in open court on the record our
FTR for the record equipment is kind of
antiquated some of it's some of the
machines that we have in the courts are
are older than others some are hooked
into our Network we have varying stages
of equipment and we're trying to replace
it as we have the funds to do that it's
the judge's responsibility to make sure
that the record is on when there's a
hearing going
as I said at the outset sometimes the
judge him or herself or court security
officer someone is actually the one
that's turning the machine on we don't
have court monitors and we've had
certainly cases where everyone thought
the record was running and the case is
done and someone files as a notice of
appeal and they go to retrieve the
record and it's not there because it was
some kind of a malfunction because we
don't have court monitors sitting there
making sure the record's you know
working all the time that's not a good
thing I would love to have court
monitors like the superior report does
which would pretty much ensure that in
every case the record will be done and
operating properly anyone can order a
copy of the audio from a hearing they do
it through the clerk's office as a fee I
think it's 25 to get a copy of the CD
transcripts are ordered through and out
we Outsource those to escribers which is
an independent company that we they
download the audio to them and they have
transcriptionists that type the record
in cases where parties are Indigent and
qualify for appointed counsel like a
public defender situation the state pays
the cost of the transcripts if it's a
civil case and the parties are appealing
or just want a copy of the record they
pay a per page cost it it goes up
depending on how quickly you want the
transcript if you want it in seven days
it's so much a page if you can wait 30
days it the cost is reduced but there
should be a record available
for every case in the Circuit Court in
Superior Court as well and and hopefully
the equipment's functioning properly the
judges during the course of a hearing I
know you may have heard some testimony
during a hearing judge doesn't have a
secret lever on the bench that they can
turn off and on
um secretly turn the record on and off
the Record is either on or it's not and
you'll if when you go to visit courts
and I encourage all of you to do that
we'll be be happy to host you on the
judge's bench you'll see a digital
display with a Time on it in Big Red
Letters and those numbers are turning
that means the records that means the
record's on the recording is on
and that the record is functioning
hopefully properly again in the Superior
Court you'll see a court monitor sitting
in front of the bench with headphones on
and they're constantly making sure all
the microphones are working and that
there's no hiccups with the record we we
don't have that we just don't have that
luxury and fortunately most of the time
the record is okay but as I said from
time to time we'll have an appeal filed
and there'll be a problem with a record
and typically in that case the case has
to be retried there's really no other
remedy so we don't want that to happen
one more question or topic
so um this question uh
why do judges call suisponty hearings
not at the request of either party can
you just sort of
tell us if that happens with any
regularity and why it might happen
it probably happens from time to time
when a case has been sitting for a
period of time and something hasn't been
scheduled for example if there were a
temporary Hearing in temporary orders
were entered and there was no order then
for a pre-trial conference or for a
final hearing whatever it might be and
the case is sat for a little while
because the court was expecting
something to be filed or something had
been filed and we were waiting for the
objection
then the court might the court clerk
might bring the case to the judge's
attention and say what's going on with
this what do we need and then we would
typically we'd look at it and typically
schedule a status conference or a
pre-trial conference if one hasn't
happened to keep the case moving
um
those are the only circumstances I can
think of outside of the emergency
category when something is filed as an
emergency and something has to happen
right away
cord is going to schedule a hearing it's
either going to be after Services
achieved on the other on the other party
or if it's a pending case it's going to
be within a period of time that the
court thinks necessary to let the
parties prepare but to get orders out as
quickly as possible after a hearing so
from time to time the clerks will bring
cases to our attention and just ask what
should we schedule here nothing's been
scheduled and we'll do that
so I guess it is suas Ponte but it's
really just typically a means of getting
the case back on track in the usual case
when we do a temporary hearing part of
the temporary orders will say Discovery
to be complete by this period of time
schedule a pre-trial conference after
discovery is complete or if the case has
limited issues and we can schedule a
final hearing with confidence that they
need the amount of time being scheduled
we'll just schedule a final hearing then
that issue is taken care of so it does
happen sometimes and and typically it's
just the Court's way of nudging the case
back onto track
thank you
well I'm going to let you bang the gavel
because I started
um
this concludes our wonderful two-hour
presentation thank you and I hope this
isn't the last I hope we'll see you
again sometime and yeah we'll take you
up on we're going to do a road trip or
two
in 26 years as a judge I never used a
gavel but I'll use it today
thank you very much thank you
okay